Ja, es gibt noch eine zweite Demo, die das so ein bisschen weiter treibt. Da kommt dann sozusagen auch noch mal die unvorhergesehenen Sachen.
Also nicht, dass ich den jetzt unterstelle, dass sie das komplett gescriptet haben, aber... Haben sie bestimmt. Das ist einfach Business, die können sie gar nicht erlauben, dass das schief geht. Also müssen sie das natürlich gut absichern.
Wollen wir den zweiten Call auch noch mal anhören?
Come over here.
Talk to me in the face.
Wie groß war eigentlich am Anfang deine Datenbasis? Also ich erinnere mich nämlich noch daran, du hast uns im Sinne von engerer Freundeskreis durfte dann antreten für die gesunden Patienten. Und weißt du noch, wie groß da, wie viele Patienten du am Anfang hattest, die erkrankt waren und wie viele dann gesund waren?
Genau. Das ist generell in der Medizin meistens so ein Problem, man hat nicht viele Daten. Also unsere erste Pilotstudie lief auf 20 MS-Patienten, 20 gesunde Kontrollen. Das wurde dann ausgeweitet auf 100 MS-Patienten und ich glaube 60 gesunde Kontrollen, was schon relativ groß ist.
Was heißt das? Also was heißt jetzt eine Kontrolle? Eine Person wird ein einziges Mal eingemessen?
Genau, das kommt auf die Studienauslegungen an. Das waren Pilotstudien, das heißt, das waren punktuelle Messungen, das war nur einmal, aber die haben dann im Prinzip unsere komplette Testbatterie einmal durchgemacht. Also einmal gehen schnell, einmal gehen langsam, einmal stehen mit offenen, geschlossenen Augen, einmal gehen auf der Stelle. Ein bisschen Hand-Assessments, also die haben im Prinzip verschiedene Messungen einmal durchgemacht. Teilweise mit Wiederholung, teilweise ohne Wiederholung, aber schon quasi punktuell an diesem einen Tag, zu diesem einen Messzeitpunkt. Genau, und dann hat man halt im Prinzip einen MS-Patienten und einen gesunden Patienten.
Das ist doch das, was Apple sagt mit ihren Apple-Herzzeugen, das durch das Phone, also das, was sie damit messen und eingeben können, dass sie hunderttausende Daten bekommen, dass das so geil wäre, weil man endlich mal so ein richtig geiles Gesamtbild kriegt und man da prima mit arbeiten kann. Das wohl für bestimmte Dinge, was das Phone halt so kann, die voll vorwärts bringt.
Genau, das ist gerade generell ein Trend in der Medizin.
Absolut nachvollziehbar. Habe ich übrigens auch gerade einen tollen Podcast so gemacht. Nee, in der Tat ging es da genau um, um diese Sachen kann ich sehr empfehlen, wenn das so ein bisschen interessiert hat. Hier bei Forschergeist Nummer 56, die digitale Medizin. Mich hier mit Sebastian Kuhn unterhalten, der ist da in Mainz und treibt so diese ganze Digitalisierung des medizinischen Bereichs von innen heraus, also als Arzt quasi voran. Und im Prinzip hat das, was wir hier schon angesprochen haben, vieles von dem, was wir da besprochen haben, gerade so dieses Ärzte überhaupt erst mal fit zu kriegen auf dieses Thema, dass sie überhaupt dann auch mal die digitale Sprache sprechen. Ich meine, dass die Informatiker sich an sie anpassen, ist ja das eine, aber ich glaube, es ist einfach auch extrem wichtig, dass wir jetzt Mediziner sehen, die auch wiederum das digitale Vokabular können und nicht nur mit dem Übersetzer an dieser Welt teilnehmen können. Gerade im Hinblick darauf, dass man eben auch so, wie ich finde, große Chancen eigentlich hat, durch eben einerseits dieses Self-Monitoring, was wir so mit der Apple Watch und dem Telefon in gewisser Hinsicht ja jetzt schon haben und vielleicht ein weiter gefasster Geschichte mit, wenn es die Kinect noch billig im Supermarkt gäbe. Gibt es jetzt gar nicht mehr, ne? Das ist ja auch blöd, ne? Aber keine Ahnung, so ein Patient kann sich ja so ein Ding irgendwie auch einfach in Raum stellen und sich die ganze Zeit messen lassen mit seinem Gang. Und in dem Moment, wo irgendwas auffällig wird, ist das halt auch gleich so ein Trigger, wo man sagt, sollte man mal schauen, wie es der Person geht.
Genau, also das ist an mehreren Stellen, also das eine ist halt wirklich so tragbare Sensorik, das heißt, Patienten werden halt mit einem etwas besser aufgewerteten Fitness-Tracker in dem Sinne ausgestattet und tragen dann die ganze Zeit und...
Könnte man das nicht, was du mit der... Ich meine, die Kinect geht doch so ein bisschen... Also Kinect funktioniert ja im Prinzip genauso wie jetzt das FaceTime auch... Halt nur dieser Strahl von vier...
Genau, Kinect 1 funktioniert, also es gibt zwei Versionen von der Kinect. Kinect 1 ist Structured Lightning, da wird halt so ein Pattern von Infrarot-Strahlen ausgesendet und im Prinzip wird die Tiefe bestimmt, in dem halt das Pattern gegen Referenzpattern verrechnet wird. Das ist nicht ganz so hoch aufgelöst. Die Kinect 2 arbeitet mit Time of Light, das heißt, da werden quasi kontinuierliche Strahlen und das ist deutlich höher auflösend, aber auch rechnintensiver und kostenintensiver. Und das, was im iPhone drin ist, ist halt so Structured Light mäßig.
Sag doch mal, was ist mit der Kinect jetzt eigentlich? Also ist die jetzt eingestellt worden?
Also...
Da kann ich gerne so ein kleines bisschen drüber rannten. Also die Kinect selbst gibt es noch, sie wird aber nicht mehr hergestellt. Das große Problem ist eigentlich, dass die Adapter, die man braucht, um die Kinect am Rechner anzuschließen, dass die aufgekauft sind. Also da gibt es jetzt nur noch China Nachbauten, die nicht so richtig...
Was ist denn das für ein Interface?
Im Prinzip braucht die Kinect extra eine Stromversorgung und die hat halt so keinen richtigen USB-Stecker, sondern... Ja, irgendein Quatsch. Genau.
Aber was ist denn das Protokoll, was sie spricht?
Keine Ahnung, das ist was Selbes. Da kommen ja auch relativ hohe Datenmengen durch. Und die Kinect selbst macht halt ein bisschen Processing auf ihrem internen Chip und ein bisschen direkt auf der Grafikkarte.
Das muss doch schon so eine High-Speed-Serie wahrscheinlich schon USB sein, aber halt nicht mit dem richtigen Standard-Connector.
Ja, aber du sprichst doch wahrscheinlich über die Kinect AP damit, ne? Die auch nochmal ein bisschen Processing macht.
Ja, das auch. Aber die Kinect 2 hat, soweit ich weiß, einen kleinen Chip, der zum Beispiel die Personenerkennung automatisch gleich intern sozusagen macht. Sodass das nicht auf CPU oder GPU laufen muss. Kinect ist discontinued, offiziell. Sie ist nicht mehr so einfach zu verwenden. Aber es gibt jetzt so die nächste Generation von Sensoren, zum Beispiel die Intel RealSense D415 und D435. Die funktionieren mit Structured Light zusätzlich zu zwei RGB-HD-Kameras. Das heißt, die haben ein etwas anderes System, um auch relativ hoch auflösende 3D-Daten zu erzeugen. Das funktioniert so weit ganz gut. Problem da ist, dass die ausverkauft sind, im Prinzip, seit sie rausgekommen sind. Das heißt, man bekommt derzeit keine von diesen Sensoren. Was auch sehr interessant ist, im Prinzip ist jetzt die Kinect 4 angekündigt. Es gibt Kinect 1, die war für die Xbox 360, Kinect 2 für die Xbox One, Kinect 3 ist quasi das, was in der Hololens verbaut ist. Und Kinect 4 ist auch wieder Time of Flight, aber kleiner und soll wohl irgendwie für Azure, RP, Azure SDK optimiert sein. Da wurde jetzt nur einmal kurz was geteased auf der Build. Also...
Achso, der Build-Developer-Konferenz von Microsoft.
Genau. Da ist also noch nicht so viel bekannt, aber ja, die arbeiten halt doch trotzdem irgendwie wir. Und das lustige ist, dass wirklich intern bei Microsoft sehr viel Unverständnis ist. Vorsichtig gesagt. Warum die discontinued wurde? Sie haben halt irgendwann die Entwickler-Kräfte abgezogen, weil die mehr an HoloLens arbeiten sollten, kann man irgendwo verstehen. Aber dass sie im Prinzip jetzt von heute auf morgen die komplette Produktion eingestellt haben, ist unverständlich.
Haben sie sich...
vielleicht im Minus gearbeitet, also mit Verlust? War das so teuer?
Glaub ich nicht. Also sie hat im Primärmarkt nicht performt, also sie wurde für Spiele entwickelt und Spiele will halt keiner, es wird sich niemand bewegen für Spiele. Ja schon.
Selbstverständlich ist das nicht richtige Plattform gewesen. Ist halt so ein bisschen die Frage, Spieleplattform gibt's halt viele und ob man sich was bei Xbox war, war Kinect und viele haben vielleicht dann doch eher sich die Nintendo-Sache erholt. Und da ist halt die Frage, das ist einfach ein großer Markt, in den sie da rein wollten, aber ich verstehe halt auch nicht, ich kann mir halt vorstellen, dass sie sich gerade ins eigene Fleisch vielleicht eher dadurch schneiden, sowas zu discontinue und wenn kleinere Unternehmen damit arbeiten.
Also das Problem war, es gab halt auch einfach nur dämliche Spiele. Es gab halt diese klassischen Tanzspiele, die klassischen Fitness-Spiele und alle anderen, die das...
Dance Dance Revolution.
Und alle anderen, die das irgendwie versucht haben zu adaptieren, da war halt das Handling nicht so richtig gut oder hat halt nicht so viel Spaß gemacht. Und es ist halt schon so, dass einen großen Teil der Leute, die gerne an Konsolen zocken, zocken zum Abschalten. Und nicht um... Engagements zu zeigen, ja. Ähm, ich kann verstehen, dass es da nicht performt hat. Ähm, aber das... Aber es war definitiv bekannt, dass die halt, dass die in der Forschung total gerne genutzt wird und dass halt auch wirklich jetzt so die ersten Systeme in dem Sinne rauskamen, die das für medizinische oder industrielle Anwendungen genutzt haben, diesen Sensor.
Und so macht das Intel mit den RealSense-Dingern? Also die ist jetzt im Prinzip funktional vergleichbar?
Hm, nicht ganz hundertprozentig, weil die Kinect des SDK hatte noch die automatische Personenerkennung drin. Das hat die Intel-Kamera nicht. Da gibt es externe APs, die dann so ein bisschen darauf aufsetzen, aber alles ist noch nicht hundertprozentig funktional.
Ja gut, aber man kriegt im Prinzip dasselbe Sensing zunächst einmal. Man kann auf jeden Fall dieselben Rohdaten liefern. Ähnliche, ja.
Ähnliche?
Vergleichbare?
Ja.
Welche, die auch gehen?
Kommt drauf an, für welche Auflösungen man braucht.
Ja, okay, aber um jetzt so einen Gang zu analysieren, geht's auch? Oder ist da irgendwas schlechter jetzt als?
Die Kinect 2 hatte schon eine sehr, sehr hohe Tiefendatenauflösung und da kommen derzeit die Sensoren nicht ganz, also die...
Es gibt keinen anderen Hersteller, der jetzt dieselbe Konzept verfolgt?
Na schon, aber die sind nicht so weit. Und die Sensoren sind teurer. Und im Prinzip ist alles, was so vergleichbar ist, schon Kinect 1 Niveau von der Qualität. Ich scheue mich halt auch zu sagen, es geht, wenn ich nicht selbst die Daten in der Hand hatte und quasi meine Algorithmen getestet habe und geguckt habe, wie ähnlich sind sie gegenüber Goldstandards. Weil die meisten Videos, die man so sieht, sagt man, könnte, aber so Realdaten sind halt auch nochmal was anderes. Und dann ist es gerade so, wie verhält sich zum Beispiel bei Randfällen, wie gut ist tatsächlich die Erkennung im so normalen Alltag mit Artefakten, wenn die erkannt oder wenn die nicht erkannt. Da spielt halt schon sehr viel rein.
Jetzt hast du ja schon erwähnt, dass in irgendeinem Teil des gesamten Prozesses du auch ein Machine Learning zum Einsatz bringst.
Man könnte. Ich persönlich mache sehr viel über Signalerkennung und klassische Statistik, weil das derzeit das ist, was die Ärzte verstehen. Und es ist halt sehr wichtig, dass im Prinzip das, was man rausgibt, keine Black Box ist.
Zu jedem Zeitpunkt nachvollziehbar ist.
Dass man was erklärt kann, was es tut. Du hast ja natürlich auch nicht die Samplesize. Letzten Endes würdest du ja mit viel zu wenig Daten lernen.
Ja, wir haben so eine Schlafanalyse-Studie gemacht, wo wir im Prinzip acht Stunden lang über die Nacht von 80 Patienten Kinect-Rodaten aufgenommen haben. Das sind so komprimiert schon 70-80 Terabyte an 3D-Rodaten.
Eine Nacht, eine Person?
Nee, insgesamt. Eine Nacht sind ungefähr 800-1 Terabyte an Daten.
Wie wären die Pennen 3D-Daten? Und das ist spannend?
Das haben wir im Schlaflabor gemacht. Das heißt, wir hatten gesunde Kontrollen. Wir hatten Patienten, die halt so periodische Beinbewegungen haben. Die hatten quasi das Bein...
Mussten die ohne Decke schlafen?
Nee, die hatten halt eine dünne Decke. Wurden komplett verkabelt, weil das klassische Bewegungsanalyse, Schlaflabor ist halt mit EEG, also Hirnableitung, Atemflussanalyse, irgendwie Elektroden an den Beinen, um Muskelkontraktionen zu gucken. Und wir hatten Patienten mit Atemaussetzern. Und im Prinzip war das halt auch so eine einfach Machbarkeitsstudie, um zu gucken, können wir Atemaussetzer detektieren? Ja, ging. Mit bisschen Voodoo. Beinbewegungen konnten wir halt auch. Was dann halt zum Beispiel spannend ist, kann man Schlafstadien, also wach, leicht Schlaf, Tiefschlaf, ob man das unterscheiden kann, rein an diesen Daten. Und da ist dann zum Beispiel definitiv Machine Learning, weil da weiß man nicht so richtig, wonach man sucht. Das ist so ein komplexes Bewegungsverhalten.
Aber da kannst du ja im Prinzip gute Positivdaten generieren, weil du ja über die anderen Sensoren das wiederum sehr gut zuverlässig feststellen kannst und dann kannst du damit ja trainieren.
Genau. Da kommt man sehr schnell in interessante Machine Learning-Probleme, weil du dann zum Beispiel Patienten hast, die haben so gut wie keine Tiefschlafphasen. Das heißt, wenn du im Prinzip allgemein für Patienten unterscheiden willst, sind die jetzt wach, schlafen die leicht oder schlafen die tief, dann hast du teilweise das Problem, dass auf spezifische Patienten der Algorithmus trainiert hat. Oder halt, dass einfach 90% für einen Patienten richtig klassifiziert wurden, aber das lag halt daran, dass der einfach 90% Tiefschlafphasen hatte. Und das sind einfach so Sachen, die man nicht in der klassischen Vorlesung, Machine Learning 101 lernt, sondern wo es dann praxisrelevant wird, aber da gibt es doch jetzt dieses JavaScript-Framework, wo man sich alles zusammenziehen und zusammenklicken kann.
Macht das mir nicht?
Doch. Wir machen das zusammen einfach. Du machst das JavaScript-Clicky-Bunty und ich geb die 80 Tala bei Daten rein.
Das hat man davon, wenn man die Tala trollt.
Man wird zurückgetrollt.
Entschuldigung, ich kann mich nicht um drei Sachen gleichzeitig kümmern.
Zwei auch nicht.
Dann kretsch ich doch einfach direkt rein. Du hast gerade schon deine Terabyte an Daten angesprochen und ich fände es super spannend, weil wir da auch viel zu selten darüber reden, was so dein Entwicklungs-Setup ist. Also ich meine, du hast eben schon gesagt, du hast mit großen Datenmengen zu tun. Du hast schon gebeichtet, dass du der Windows-Nutzer bist. Spoiler.
Das ist die erste Windows-Userin hier in unserer Sendung, glaube ich.
Ja, ich weiß. Ich schäme mich ernsthaft. Ich bin C-Shop-Entwicklerin.
Das hält jetzt aber in Lächeln auf den Lippen.
Ja, sieht nicht so nach echtem Schämen aus.
Na, ich...
Ach so, unter der Schminke vielleicht.
Ich muss sagen, ich mag Windows 10. Es ist von den Windows-Betriebssystemen, die ich bis jetzt hatte und haben musste, das Beste. Es ist so ein bisschen Stockholm-Syndrom.
Erinnerst du dich noch, als wir in diesem Dark Side Bakery-Dings waren für Windows 8, als das gerade ausgekommen ist?
Ich hab meinen geliebten kleinen Mac zu Hause. Ich muss aber sagen, Apple hat es ein bisschen bei mir verkackt, weil das Letzte, was ich mochte, war Snow Leo. Danach haben die grundlegende Lieblingsfeature von mir rausgestrichen und ich dachte mir, so. Ich glaube primär waren es die Duel, also die... Spaces, mit denen ich exzessiv gearbeitet habe.
Also, dass sie in zwei Dimensionen gab und nicht nur in einer.
Ah, stimmt.
Bevor wir dann vielleicht kurz zu deinem Entwicklungsfeld kommen, Rainer weist uns gerade auf etwas hin, ob wir das kennen, über das Testing der Software-Hardware-Komponenten in der Medizin-Informatik. Also ich kann dazu, wie das Testing so vonstatten geht, weil in dem Artikel, den er da verlinkt, geht es glaube ich um so große Rücklaufzahlen von Software. Also ich kann da glaube ich nur bedingt, also ich weiß nicht, wir hatten das jetzt so mal von unserem Entwicklungszettel, also um das nochmal vorweg zu sagen, Tala und ich haben früher in derselben Firma kurzzeitig gearbeitet und wir haben in der Medizin-Software immer Tests geschrieben, aber ich glaube nicht zum Beispiel Test-Driven gearbeitet.
Ne, also Unit-Tests und Integrationstests ist bei uns Standard. Bei klassischen, in Anführungszeichen, Medizinprodukte, Entwicklungsbuden, die sind halt immer noch auf dem Stand von vor 20, 30 Jahren. Das heißt V-Modell Unit-Tests werden nur, wenn da nur, spärlich gemacht. Es werden alte Sprachen verwendet und ganz ehrlich, es wundert mich nicht, wenn dort Produkte massive Mängel aufweisen. Es ist eigentlich erstaunlich, dass man darüber nicht öfter was hört.
Was sind denn alte Programmiersprachen?
Ich weiß, dass die für ein Krankenhaus-Informationssystem ASPNET genutzt haben.
Und ich glaube auch, es gab ein Open Source Krankenhaus-Informationssystem, was sogar ein PHP geschrieben war.
Okay, ich dachte, ihr meint jetzt sowas wie Kobol oder...
Nicht ganz so alt. Es sind keine Banken, aber... Ja, fast schon.
Aber in was war denn diese komische Software geschrieben, die die Röntgenbilder verwaltet hatte?
Oh, das kann sein.
Das war doch irgendwas Komiles.
Das war glaube ich so eine Marke Eigenbau angefangen und ist dann zu einer richtigen Standard-Medizin-Software gewonnen. Aber ich weiß auch nicht mehr, woran die... Das könnte so die... Aber Hardware-Testing. Hardware-Testing. Hardware-Testing ist fies. Kann ich leider aus eigener Sache sagen. Da kommt's natürlich drauf an, was man... Genau, also Richtung Medizinprodukte-Zertifizierung. Also alles, was so eingebaut werden muss oder was direkt mit Patienten interagiert, braucht im Normalfall, wenn es für medizinische Zwecke verwendet wird, eine Medizinprodukte-Zertifizierung. Die sind aber eher so auf dem Level, du musst nach Stand der Technik entwickeln. Was sowohl Security angeht als auch Best Practices. Und im Prinzip sind halt die ganzen Zertifizierungen angelegt auf V-Modellentwicklung. V-Modell ist eine Art Software zu entwickeln, mit erst alle Spezifizierungen runterschreiben, dann stringent Code runterschreiben.
Also Wasserfall oder wie?
Nee, nee, dann hast du noch mal durch Wasserfall. Eins nach Wasserfall ist halt eine Iteration, dass du sowas wie Tests usw. und dann noch mal so, also so eine kleine Iterationsstufe mit denkst.
Du machst im Prinzip Wasserfall und wenn du unten angebaut bist, überprüfst du jede einzelne Stufe wieder hoch. Ja, richtig, richtig schön. Und da, ja, also generell so agile Softwareentwicklung, schnell auf Probleme reagieren, iteratives Testen, iteratives Verbessern, funktioniert immer noch nicht so richtig gut mit Softwareentwicklung und Medical Devices.
Ich hau mal den Link dazu in den Schlett. Das ist das V-Modell.
Und das ist, ja. Und Hardware Testing, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es da direkte regulatorische Vorgaben gibt, was man alles machen muss. Also du musst halt im Prinzip zeigen, dass es unbedenklich ist, dass kein Risiko für den Patienten entsteht. Und wenn du das gezeigt hast, dann ist von regulatorischer Seite gut. Viel wird aber dann auch erst im Markt getestet. Das heißt, wenn dann im Markt Fehler auftreten, wird halt zurückgerufen. Und ich hatte am Anfang, als ich halt mit Kinect entwickelt habe, das Problem, dass ich keine Möglichkeit hatte, diese Kinect-Daten in irgendeiner Form zu recorden und zu emulieren. Also wenn ich was getestet habe, wenn ich was ausprobieren wollte, muss ich die ganze Zeit da vorne rumtornen.
Und irgendwann hast du es doch aber geschafft, Videos dann auch einzuspeisen in den Input, oder?
Ja genau, das ist eine der angenehmen Sachen von Kinect SDK, dass die im Prinzip eine Schnittstelle hatten, wo man Rohdaten aufzeichnen konnte, die man wieder in diese API einspeisen konnte. Also du hattest dann einen emulierten Sensor. Das ist schon was, was dann auch gerade erst überhaupt automatisiertes Testen ermöglicht hat, weil du vorher recorden konntest und du hattest so einen halbwegs deterministischen Prozess, wo dann meistens das Gleiche am Ende rausgekommen ist. Das ist nicht ganz so angenehm und trivial. Hätte man am liebsten schöner, aber ja.
Um mal Tims Lieblingsspruch zu sagen, wir hatten ja nichts.
Ich bin schon ein bisschen sehr glücklich mit den Daten, die ich im Prinzip habe und mit den Sachen, die ich machen kann. Das ist für viele nicht ganz so selbstverständlich, weil allein erstmal an Patientendaten ranzukommen, ist schwierig. Da braucht man im Prinzip halt dann medizinische Studienärzte, mit denen man irgendwie klarkommt. Aber das ist halt auch irgendwie wichtig.
Nicht, dass man im Klartext die Patientendaten übermittelt bekommt. Das sind unsere Daten. Ja, da steht wirklich die Adresse drin. Ja, das auch. Aber dann vielleicht doch jetzt noch mal zu deinem Setup. Wie entwickelst du? 70 Terabyte Daten ist jetzt ja auch nicht unbedingt der kleinste Datensatz.
Nee, eigentlich bräuchten wir ein komplettes Rechencluster, wo wir die Daten ablegen können und dann durchlaufen lassen. Geht halt für uns nicht. Und die Daten auch an zum Beispiel eine andere Universität zu geben, die halt so ein Rechencluster hat, ist sehr aufwendig wegen Datenschutzerklärung. Und im Prinzip muss jeder Patient einzeln einstimmen. Das heißt, es muss vor so einer Studie eigentlich angedacht werden, dass...
Sind die Daten nicht anonymisiert?
Das sind Videodaten, die kannst du nicht anonymisieren.
Du kannst eine Katze übers Gesicht kleben.
Also das ist nicht so einfach. Und Patentendaten sind ja noch mal zusätzlich geschützt. Da war das wirklich so Batch-Processing. Das heißt, im Prinzip meine Algorithmenentwicklung mache ich primär in Matlab. Das heißt, alles so, wenn ich anfange, neue Analysen zu schreiben, wenn ich anfange, neue Sachen zu entwickeln, nicht software-technisch, sondern wirklich analysemäßig, ist das halt, ja, Matlab. Dann hab ich da irgendwann meine Feature oder meine Klassifikation. Das Ganze muss dann irgendwie noch mit den demografischen Patientendaten, Stammdaten, halt außer Charité oder außer Klinik gemercht werden. Das funktioniert dann meistens über SPSS oder Excel, weil natürlich an Kliniken und auch in der Forschung, die haben nicht so viel.
Haben die aber nicht. Ach so, Matlab ist zu teuer.
Matlab ist relativ teuer und das Problem ist, viele der Leute können auch nicht so gut mit Matlab umgehen, dass das Matching funktioniert. Also das ist tatsächlich eine der größten Probleme immer wieder und die können aus meiner Sicht auch nicht so richtig reduziert werden. Kombinationen von verschiedenen Datenquellen, Zusammenführen von verschiedenen Datenquellen, das ist immer sehr viel manueller Aufwand und immer eklig, egal was man macht. Aber dann hab ich halt irgendwann mein hübsches, bereinigtes Datenset und dann kommt im Prinzip die Statistik, die ich je nachdem meistens in Python mache. Wenn ich mit Ärzten oder mit anderen Sachen, also Doktoranden zum Beispiel, zusammenarbeite, dann muss das halt aber auch wieder SPSS sein, weil die keinen Python können. Die können meistens noch nicht mal R. Das ist also R.
Das Gegenstück zu S?
Ja, R ist in den Kreisen ja sehr verbreitet, ne?
Ja, also viele der Mediziner nutzen halt lieber R als, oder Medizinforscher nutzen lieber R.
Vielleicht jetzt hier unsere Hörer auch nochmal kurz erklären, was R und was S ist und so, weil ich glaube, das wissen die einfach alle nicht.
Und was MATLAB vielleicht auch was da steht.
MATLAB vielleicht auch, weil ich bin ganz ehrlich, so ganz hundertprozentig bin ich das auch nicht.
Na ja, MATLAB ist halt ein Environment, was halt optimiert ist für Programme, die mit Mathe arbeiten.
Matrizen vor allem, ne? Datenanalyse, Matrizen ist so die Stärke.
Bildanalyse ganz viel. Die haben inzwischen auch Schnittstellen zu verschiedenen Robotikeinheiten. Das ist schon relativ high level, auch aktuelle Forschungs-Sachen sind halt dort hinterlegt. Das heißt, wenn man zum Beispiel eine Gesichtserkennung auf Bilder laufen lassen will, hat man so die implementierten Standard-Algorithmen, sodass man die einfach nur aufrufen muss.
Aber Matlab gibts da auch schon seit ewig, oder? Das heißt, es wurde durch Module immer erweitert und sozusagen sie, ja ok.
Genau, aber es ist halt ein Produkt und hat natürlich die entsprechenden Probleme. Wie hieß die?
Welche Preis-Liga reden wir da so bei diesem Topf?
Beim unten rechts Modell, womit du wirklich gut arbeiten kannst, bist du glaube ich bei 75k? Ja, der ist krass teuer.
Ja, also das ist dann so die Uni-Lizenz mit all and everything und hier hab Spaß. Im Prinzip geht die Basis-Variante glaube ich bei 500 bis 1000 Euro los, je nachdem, ob du individuellen oder Firmen-Lizenz haben willst.
Aber selbst wenn du Prof bist oder Forscher bist, weil ich erinnere mich da sehr gut dran, unser Prof hat das mal erzählt, dass sie nur so zwei, also das Hauptmodul von Matlab brauchten und ich glaube zwei oder drei Erweiterungen und selbst sie waren relativ schnell so bei 50k im Projekt.
Ja, das haben die irgendwann umgestellt, das muss man sagen, es ist günstiger geworden, es ist aber immer noch relativ teuer und... Definitiv.
Wir haben auch mal versucht, Oktaf zu benutzen, aber da hast du das mal so richtig gut zum Laufen bekommen, wie Matlab, so von der Sweetness, wie man es benutzt und wie es halt so ist, war halt irgendwie nie so richtig da.
Ja, also es ist je nachdem, was man machen will, eine gute Alternative. Ich glaube für mich hat das meistens nicht funktioniert aus verschiedensten Gründen. Etwa brauchte ich irgendwelche Algorithmen, die halt nicht vorhanden waren oder generell, ich muss sagen, ich mag auch, wie Matlab das Datenhandling gestaltet, also wie man mit den Daten interagieren kann, was man sich anzeigen lassen kann und so weiter und so fort.
Was ist denn Mathematika dann im Vergleich zu Matlab?
Ja, habe ich so nicht genutzt.
Ja, Mathematika ist halt um sozusagen, also ich bin da alles andere als ein Experte, aber es ist halt weniger zum, ich programmiere da drin Software, die mit vielen Daten umgeht und darauf viel Mathematik anwendet. Versus Mathematika ist die Mathematik als solche. Herleitung, Ableitung, Formel, Auflösung, sozusagen das eigentliche mathematische Gerüst, also das, was ein Mathematiker macht, um Mathematik zu machen, Mathematik zu forschen, ja, um sozusagen Lösungen zu finden. Matlab ist die Anwendung dessen.
Weil ich habe zum Beispiel, als bei Art & Com diese kinetische Skulptur fürs BMW-Museum gemacht wurde, da hat der David, den vielleicht auch noch kennst, der Herr Siegel, der hat, glaube ich, mit Mathematika die Formeln für die Bewegungsprofile für diese ganzen Kugeln und so entwickelt. Da drin gebastelt.
Aber dann nicht mit Mathematika live angewendet, sondern eigentlich was anderes angewendet.
Der hat den Mathematiker geprototitert und als es dann ging, hat er also sein Programm übernommen, weil man da schneller spielen kann, ohne umprogrammieren zu müssen.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Was ich jetzt sehr lustig finde, weil ich war gerade irritiert, als Tim den Link von Octave zur Wikipedia gepostet hat. Die haben jetzt eine grafische Oberfläche. Hast du das gerade gesehen? Also ich meine, ja. Im Jahre 2015 sind sie dann auch schon komplett auf eine stabile UI aufgewechselt. Weil ich erinnere mich nämlich daran, als wir das so versucht haben zu benutzen, hast du nur eine Konsole gehabt. Und der Vergleich zu Matlab, wo du halt wirklich auch ein bisschen UI bekommst, ein bisschen Hilfe, wenn du dich in einem neuen Thema einnerden möchtest, war dann halt so ein bisschen angenehmer.
Die aktuelle Octave UI schaut für mich so ein bisschen aus wie RStudio, was halt...
Ja, eben, stimmt.
Ja, eine R-IDI auch so mit ein bisschen...
Ich glaub, das muss ich mal runterladen.
Ja, und R, um mal Muckes Frage nochmal abschließend zu erörtern, ist ja eine Sprache, die vor allem auf so statistische Auswertung hin aktiviert ist.
Ja, aber auch viele Physiker und auch Mathematiker, die kommen halt im Prinzip von ihren mathematischen Formeln und entdecken dann R als Programmiersprache für sich. Das hat halt schon eine etwas mathematischere Notation und ich mag einfach... Ich als Software-Entwickler, Programmierer, mag einfach die Syntax auch nicht so richtig und wie da bestimmte Sachen gedacht werden.
Aber, was ich ein R schon geil finde, ist, dass die Referenzimplementierung für verschiedenste Algorithmen haben, also so richtig das, was Stand der Technik Ladies and Greatest ist, wo wir zum Beispiel bei SciPy oder wie die nicht alle heißen, halt so der, ja okay, ich hack das jetzt mal, Approach ist und dass zum Beispiel, ich glaube, die Integer- Samples aus einer Pension-Verteilung rausziehen, das ist quasi genau so wie es sein soll, das schnellste, effizienteste, beste an Algorithmen haben sie da eingebaut und bei den meisten anderen, wo ich dann so geguckt habe, war das halt immer so diese 0815 Pi mal Daumen-Implementierung. Und da ich für ein Projekt mal so ein paar statistische Verteilungen und random Samples und so generieren brauchte, habe ich dann den C-Code von R in Erlang nachimplementiert und konnte es halt mit A verifizieren, dass sozusagen die Histogramme und so alle gleich sind. Und da dachte ich mir, okay, R, weil ich habe erst bei Python und so geguckt, weil dann dachte ich mir, okay, sieht so ein bisschen aus wie Rubel, das kann ich wahrscheinlich leichter lesen als diesen trockenen C-Code, den da irgendein Typ vor 20 Jahren an der Uni geschrieben hat. Aber ja, immerhin. Also da möchte ich die R-Fahne kurz mal hochhalten. Wer sozusagen schnell auch mal bestimmte Sachen haben will, ist man mit R vielleicht besser bedient als zum Beispiel mit Zeitpie oder sowas.
Ja, definitiv. Also R hat definitiv seine Daseinsberechtigung. Ich habe es auch eine Zeit lang genutzt. Da, wo es für mich halt dann an die Grenzen kommt, ist solange du halt, sobald du halt nicht nur einen einzelnen Skript brauchst, was du jetzt einmal laufen lässt, sondern eigentlich Code hast, der weiterentwickelt, gewartet, übernommen werden soll, da ist R dann schon so ein bisschen schwierig. Und das ist auch das, was ich leider bei uns aus der Forschungsabteilung, also die ganzen Medizin-Wissenschaftler nutzen halt jetzt so langsam R, was schon besser ist als SPSS. Aber die entwickeln halt im Prinzip ihre R-Skripte so vor sich hin und dann werden die per E-Mail verschickt und dann nochmal angepasst. Und wenn der Doktorand dann promoviert hat...
Slashfeine unterstrich feine feine feine Entwörtig feine.
Also ja, da kann man halt leider so von der Software-Entwicklung doch noch so ein bisschen lernen.
Ja gut, aber in den meisten Programmiersprachen kann man Wurstkot fabrizieren und den nicht in Gittel pflegen und so weiter. Aber ARA hat auf jeden Fall auch so einen gewissen Pearl-Charme.
Ja, also alleine schon sinnvolles Unit-Testing, was einfach geht, würde ich mir fair wünschen.
Im SPSS vielleicht auch noch zu erwähnen, es ist auch eine Statistik-Software, die aber sehr viel mehr UI basiert und du musst nicht programmieren können.
Also es wird hier von Psychologen benutzt, oder?
Exel of Doge.
Aber sag mal, wie ist das denn jetzt eigentlich? Ich dachte, man darf es in der Medizin nicht benutzen, für die medizinische Statistik. Das hat uns der Prof mal gesagt.
Man muss nur wissen, wie man es benutzt. Also das Problem bei allen Verfahren ist einfach, wenn du nicht weißt, was du tust, kannst du alles rausbekommen. Genau, und das macht halt SPSS sehr leicht.
Genau, und ich dachte, deswegen sollte man das nicht benutzen? Oder war es nicht zugelassen?
Doch, doch, du kannst es ruhig nutzen. Also deshalb hatten wir es ja im Studium uns auch mal angeguckt.
Vielleicht ist es falsch abgespeichert.
SPSS hat zum Beispiel jetzt auch eine Scripting Unit. Also du kannst dort auch SPSS-Skripte schreiben. Teilweise sollen die wohl irgendwie sogar in Python gehen. Ich hab's nicht zum Laufen gekriegt. Weiß nicht, ob das jetzt für SPSS oder für mich spricht.
Das wurde in Java entwickelt? Ja. Ach du Scheiße. Ja, weil ich das da grad sehe, genau.
Das ist von 168.
Ja, aber da steht ja Entwickler IBM, Programmiersprache Java.
Ja gut, mittlerweile haben sie es vielleicht neu geschrieben.
Ich glaube, ein Großteil von Matlab ist auch in Java. Zumindest die UI. Man kann in Matlab inzwischen auch UI entwickeln. Für so Tools. Die schaut aber aus wie Windows Forms und basiert, glaube ich, auf Java.
Ja, Java, ABT oder Swing. Wahrscheinlich dieses ABT.
Ich kriege tatsächlich auch öfter mal, wenn ich zu viele Daten verarbeite, Java Runtime Exceptions in Matlab.
Was ist das für eine Typografie-Katastrophe von einem Logo?
Das spiegelt nur das Java, was dahinter liegt hier.
Man kann inzwischen auch Machine Learning-Sachen mit PSS machen. Das heißt, die Psychologen können...
Haben die ja auch eine Blockchain? Da bin ich beruhigt.
In den Chat reinschmeißen. Sind wir gerade noch irgendwo mitten drin?
Wir waren mit in Toolset, aber... Um das noch mal zusammenzufassen, weil du hast jetzt gerade die Skripte und Datenverarbeitung abgearbeitet, aber du startest so im Prinzip mit den Daten, mit so MATLAB slash Python oder vielleicht auch R. Und danach, du hast ja auch noch deine C-Sharp-Entwicklung. Ist das noch irgendwo miteinander?
Ganz ganz vorne unsere Software zur Datenaufnahme ist C-Sharp. Mit so ein ganz kleines bisschen C++. Aber primär C-Sharp für halt Kinect Rohdatenaufnahme. Dann wird das exportiert und in MATLAB reingeladen. Da Verarbeitungsschiene, dann das aus MATLAB raus, wird irgendwie gemerged mit den klinischen Daten. Und das kommt dann bei mir in Python oder R oder SPSS rein. Also ich hab so eine sehr variable...
Aber die Auswertung, die in der Software dann wieder sichtbar macht den Ärzten, ist dann quasi nur das, was aus der Kinect gerade rausgefallen ist und noch nicht die...
Na doch, also wenn ich einmal im Prinzip in MATLAB Algorithmen entwickelt habe und zum Beispiel publiziert habe und gesagt habe, ok, diese Parameter sind jetzt tatsächlich interessant, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, für den Krankheitsverlauf oder so, dann nehme ich im Prinzip den Algorithmen, den ich einmal entwickelt habe und übersetze ihn wieder in C-Sharp oder C++ und baue sie in unsere Software ein.
Da hast du dein V-Modell wieder.
Das ist vollkommen agil. Das ist agil Prototypen, Implementation. Es ist furchtbar. Aber ich bin irgendwie darauf hängen geblieben.
Ich hab nur Angst, dass ich irgendwas vergesse zu sagen. Und das wort mir schon die ganze Zeit, dass ich das nicht gleich am Anfang weggebracht hab.
Haben wir noch andere Themen?
Darf ich kurz erwähnen, dass ein Hörer neulich zu mir sagte, die Freak Show ist mein neuer Lieblingspodcast, wenn es um Outdoorsachen geht.
Das ist immer. Ja, du setzt halt hier die Trends.
Na, auch Huckel mit dem Segeln.
Ja, Huckel sitzt ja schon lange in den Trends. Ich wiederum versorge die Allgemeinheit mit ungenauen Informationen.
Ja, wie viele Hörer haben sich denn jetzt hochverschuldet beim Finanzamt an keiner?
Ja, ich hoffe noch niemand, weil ich hab natürlich Unsinn erzählt das letzte Mal und das muss ich hier auf jeden Fall nochmal begradigen. Mir sind da ein bisschen die Pferde durchgegangen, dieser ganzen Diskussion, sodass ich es dann am Ende geschafft hab, wirklich mehrere Dinge in einen Topf zu schmeißen, die da einfach nix drin verloren haben. Aber ich freue mich natürlich auch immer über diese kritische Begleitung dieses Formates, sodass mir per Mail, per Twitter, den Kommentaren sozusagen eigentlich auf allen erdenklichen Kanälen in kürzester Zeit da der Kopf gewaschen wurde. Kurz gesagt, mein Hinweis zur Abschreibung war natürlich ein Blödsinn. Ja, nee, nicht April, April. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, ich war irgendwie in Rage und dann hab ich irgendwie auf alle alles durcheinander geworfen. Also, um das mal kurz klarzustellen, man jetzt so ein neues Gerät kauft, es abschreibt über drei Jahre, dann hat es natürlich dann am Schluss, wenn es zwar einen Buchwert von 0 Euro hat, also abgeschrieben ist, ja, heißt es noch lange nicht, dass es dann sozusagen gleich vogelfrei ist, sondern wenn man es dann quasi in Privatbesitz überführt oder irgendwie verkauft, dann, neuer Begriff, den ich gelernt habe, ist ein gemeiner Wert anzunehmen, der, äh, weiß nicht ganz genau, wie der sich jetzt genau macht, also festlegt, also im Wesentlichen sozusagen so der Restwert, der Restmarktwert, der dann anzunehmen ist. Hier ist teilweise von 60 Prozent geredet, ich hab das jetzt nicht wirklich nachgerechnet oder nachgeschlagen. Brauche jetzt auch glaube ich nicht weiter auszuführen, aber ich wollte das auf jeden Fall mal abgehakt haben. Dass hier keiner glaubt, ich würde jetzt hier beliebig auf Quatsch bestehen, tue ich nicht.
Aber, also bleibt denn deine These bestehen, dass das Gerät nichts kostet im Wesentlichen?
Nein, aber meine These bleibt bestehen, dass ich natürlich nach wie vor der Meinung bin, aus vielen anderen Gründen, die ich jetzt aber nicht nochmal alle aufzählen will, dass du natürlich mit Max und insbesondere mit High-End-Max einen erheblichen Werterhalt hast, den du so mit anderer Hardware nicht hast.
Ist es quasi eine bessere Anlage, in Hardware zu investieren?
Anlage ist ja nicht so, dass es dir Geld bringt. Die Frage ist ja, was sind sozusagen die Kosten, die du für Gerätschaft hast? Und da musst du halt alles mit reinwerfen, da musst du reinwerfen, was bringt dir das Gerät? Also wie gut leistet es die Dienste? Wie zuverlässig? Wie wenig ist so ein Gerät in der Reparatur? Klar, da gibt's immer mal wieder Montagsgeräte und schlechte Serien. Da haben wir alles schon tausendmal diskutiert. Ich hab so den Eindruck, dass dieser iMac Pro jetzt schon so ein Device ist, was eher so gute Noten bekommt. Also zumindest hat man seit dem Release relativ wenig Schlechtes darüber gehört. Mag natürlich auch daran sein, dass die Zielgruppe nicht so groß ist, aber wir wissen auch, dass wenn irgendwas Schlimmes vorfällt, dass dann einer auch reicht und dann ist das ganze Internet schon wieder am schmelzen in dieser Hinsicht. Und das ist auch, sagen wir mal, meine Erfahrungen gewesen, die ich früher gehabt hab. Also allein mein allererster Macintosh hat mich damals, das war ein Mac 2Ci, da hab ich irgendwie mit Laserdruckern, der war noch gebraucht, da hab ich irgendwie 10.000 Mark ausgegeben. Und 10.000 Mark war halt so 92, ja, so gefühlt wie heute 10.000, ne, ja nicht 10.000 Euro.
Aber war schon, war schon auch nicht wenig, auf jeden Fall. War schon ein gehobenes Niveau.
Mehr als 10.000 Euro.
Weiß ich nicht.
Meinst du?
Glaub schon.
So viel Inflation? 50, 20 Jahre?
Über 20 Jahre. Zins und Zinseszins und so?
Na, 30. Ja gut, wie auch immer. Also war teuer, so, keine Frage, aber war halt auch mit Abstand die beste Investition, die ich je gemacht hab. Weil ich das Ding gleich so wunderbar zum Einsatz bringen konnte, hatte ich natürlich ein bisschen Glück gehabt, dass ich die passenden Jobs bekommen hab. Aber ich war halt in der Lage, mit dem Gerät Dinge zu tun, die einfach mit keinem anderen Gerät möglich gewesen wären.
So, ja.
Ich konnte mich irgendwie hinten im Kofferraum packen, irgendwo auftauchen und ich war eine wandelnde Druckmaschine. Lichtsatz- und Druckausbelichtungsmaschine. Ich konnte irgendwie mit der Tastatur irgendeine Dokumentation eintippern und Apfel-P machen. Und es kam halt in ordentlichen 300 dpi aus diesem kleinen Lesser-Drucker raus. Und ich weiß noch, wie damals die Leute wirklich reinweise hinten übergekippt sind, weil sie einfach gedacht haben, ich bin vom anderen Stern. Was sie nicht gewohnt sind. Und es war ja auch nicht normal, in besser Hinsicht.
Vielleicht lag das auch an deinem Haarschnitt.
Das war nicht anders als heute.
Hattest du nicht längere Haare mal? Habe ich nicht irgendwann ein Foto gesehen?
Ich hatte ein Jahr in meinem Leben, hatte ich mal längere Haare. Ich hab sie halt mal ein Jahr lang nicht wachsen lassen.
Nicht abgeschnitten.
Ja, das war alles. Das war so eine verrückte Phase.
Aber mit diesem Hardware, also ich würde das ja auch generell sagen, weil ich ja mit Audio-Hardware jetzt auch schon zum Beispiel seit längerem beschäftigt bin. Und jetzt wollte ich mir mal letztens ein ordentliches Upgrade besorgen und dachte mir, dafür müsste ich aber ehrlicherweise mal auch so einen ganzen Stapel von alten Sachen verkaufen. Und es hat erstaunlich gut funktioniert. Und bin jetzt auch bei plus minus null quasi wieder rausgekommen, was auch daran lag, dass ich schon damals jetzt nicht unbedingt Scheiß gekauft habe. Aber ja, da bestätigt sich das auf jeden Fall.
Auf die null kann man schon kommen, weil am Ende einfach, auch wenn man es dann wieder verbuchen muss, man eigentlich Einnahmen hat für gebrauchter Hardware, die ja, egalisiert den Preis. Und wenn du es dann auf die genutzte Zeit runterbrichst, dann wird es auf einmal doch sehr billig. Und meine Erfahrung ist halt, umso besser du kaufst, umso mehr hast du davon.
Na, wenn jemand was gebrauchtes haben will, dann ja schon das geile Zeug, weil er kriegt sehr billige, das ganz billige Zeug will keiner gebraucht haben, weil ja, das kann man sich dann auch selber holen.
In diesem Sinne sollte irgendjemand ein gut erhaltenes MacBook Air von 2015 mit 8GB RAM und 512 SSD zu verkaufen haben. Ich hätte Interesse. Ich muss mir ja mal einen neuen Mac kaufen und leider hat Apple ja kein Angebot.
Aber in elf Tagen und 21 Stunden ist doch die WWDC.
Also traditionell keine Hardware vorgestellt.
Ach so, leider gut, dass man mir das nochmal sagt.
Ich glaube, dass die Durststrecke wird noch mindestens ein Jahr, wenn nicht sogar zwei Jahre dauern, wenn nicht 20 Jahre. Und ich hab neulich halt überlegt, was machst du jetzt? Und für mich gibt es eigentlich nur zwei Optionen und beides ist halt neu, nicht mehr zu kriegen und gebraucht nur so, hm, andere, wo ich mich vielleicht noch zu breit schlagen würde, wär so ein 13 Zoll MacBook Pro 2015 im Vollausbau.
2015 wegen der Tastatur?
Wegen allem.
Was noch außer der Tastatur?
Kein Fall. Ist nicht freigegeben.
Ich muss ja leider sagen, dass ich das USB-C jetzt doch irgendwie mag. Weil ich diesen wunderbaren Anker, dieses wunderbare Anker-Ladegerät habe, wo du ein USB-C-Port hast, normale USB-Ports hast und wenn du in den Urlaub fährst, das hab ich gleich schon mal gesagt, das ist einfach das Geilste.
Den Rechner vom Akku laden zu können.
Du hast nur noch ein Lade-Device, was du mit dir rumschleppen musst. Die Situation ist folgende, wenn du im Ausland bist, die jetzt nicht diesen Euro-Stecker haben, ist ja wurscht, dann hast du überall Strom. Aber wenn du ins Ausland gehst, du brauchst deinen Steckeradapter. Also ich hab jedenfalls nicht immer Bock, so eine Horde Elektro-Schrott mit mir nach Südamerika zu schleppen, nur damit ich irgendwie all meine Devices an einem Stromgerät laden kann. Und wenn du so ein USB-C-Port hast zum Stromladen, hast du halt deinen Anker USB-C-USB-Schnuffel, wo du dein Handy reinschmeißen kannst. Du hast ja auch eine Apple Watch, dann hast du wahrscheinlich auch das iPad. Und dann dieses USB-C-USB-Schnuffel. Nein, aber normales USB ist ja auch dran. Da hast du so einen... Ja, ich schick euch einen Link. Moment kurz. Das ist einfach, ich weiß nicht, damit macht's im Urlaubfahren noch mehr Spaß, weil man einfach direkt das Richtige... Danke. Device am Start hat. Device muss ich nicht eingeben bei Amazon. Moment.
Sprechen und tippen.
Deswegen mag ich das mit dem USB-C, weil ich hab das Ding gerade bei mir am Bett liegen. Das heißt, wenn ich keinen Bock mehr habe, an meinem Schreibtisch zu arbeiten, schnapp ich mir den USB-C-Rechner, nehme den mit ins Bett, hab dann mein Telefon und alles gleich dabei. Ich hab halt nur noch ein Gerät, was ich halt mit mir rumschleppen muss.
Ja, naja, also ich meine, du musst ja noch eine Tastatur mitschleppen, ne?
Wir haben aber jetzt über USB-C geredet und nicht über Tastatur.
Genau, also das geht schon mittlerweile. Also ich hasse sie auch wie die Pest, aber...
Also der Kollege von mir, der die größeren Probleme hat, der hat jetzt irgendwie rausgefunden, dass man sich ja die neuere Tastatur in das ältere MacBook Pro auch einbauen lassen kann im Apple Store. Und das hat er jetzt wohl, glaube ich, gemacht und hat den Rechner heute wieder abgeholt. Ich hab ihn jetzt aber noch nicht...
Ist das eine Legende oder ist das Fakt? Hast du das gesehen? Mit eigenen Augen?
Er hat das jetzt sozusagen machen lassen. Also er hat mir gesagt...
Wait a minute, wait a minute. Die 2016er Tastatur getauscht gegen von vorher?
Nee, gegen die 17er.
Aber da muss ja das ganze Top Case sein.
Weil die 17er, die ist genauso flach und doof von der Flachheit, aber die ist wohl nicht mehr so ganz anfällig gegen den Dreck, weil sie da irgendwie das Plastik ein bisschen geändert haben. So ist die Legende, aber so richtig bewiesen ist das noch nicht, oder?
Er wird es ausprobieren.
Also ob da jetzt wirklich die Reparaturraten runtergegangen sind, das weiß glaube ich nur Apple. Aber für mich kommt dieses Gerät nicht in Frage. Sorry. Also die Tastatur geht einfach aus so vielen Gründen nicht.
Aber guck mal, deine kleine Tastatur, die du da hast, kannst du ja quasi mitnehmen.
Ah, die 2017er ist auch deutlich leiser angeblich.
Naja, aber nicht leiser als die 2015er.
Ich werde es mal testen beim Kollegen.
Gopmen in die Tüte, ist abgewählt, nehme ich nicht, mag ich nicht. Apple, kannst du in A stecken, das Teil. Seit 1990 bin ich da Kunde. Seit 1990.
Ich war noch nie so gepisst.
Noch nie. Als ich dieses Air hier gekauft habe, das war für mich die Krönung der Schöpfung. Das war wirklich in dem Moment das geilste seit geschnitten Brot. Die perfekte Maschine für mich. Und dann haben sie aufgehört, die perfekte Maschine zu perfektionieren. Das nehme ich ihnen echt übel.
Overfitting. Überperfektioniert.
Wer, ich oder die oder das Gerät? Das Gerät.
Das ist das allgemeine Problem des 21. Jahrhunderts. Dieser Drang, Probleme zu lösen, die keiner hat.
Ja, habe ich so ein bisschen auch das Gefühl. Vor allem hören die auf ihre Kunden nicht.
Oder auf die falschen Kunden.
Nee, die hören nicht.
Das ist ja auch eine Kraft, an die Dinge zu denken, an die eigentlich keiner denkt.
Das muss aber auch passen. Es muss auch passen. Es geht gar nicht. Die haben keinen gefragt. Kannst du mir nicht erzählen?
Ja. Die haben ja vorher schon jahrelang.
Und keiner kann mir erzählen, dass jemand irgendwann gesagt hat, dass diese Cursor-Tasten besser sind. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Also die Cursor-Tasten, die Tastengröße, die Abstände, das Fühl, die Zuverlässigkeit, das sind allein schon mal vier oder fünf Punkte. Und die Escape-Taste, sechs oder fünf.
Drei sind es gleich.
Also genug Gründe, warum diese Tastatur schon nicht geht. Dann sind diese Dinger auch sinnlos dünner. Und haben hier so richtig keinen Vorteil, außer dass die ordentlichen Pots nicht mehr reichen.
Vor allem, wenn sie meinen, dass hier so dieses Touchbar nur als Keyboard-Erweiterung benutzt werden soll und nicht zur Anzeige von Informationen. Aber mal ehrlich, seit wann geht ein fucking Keyboard in Sleep Mode? Meine Tasten sind weg. Entweder ist es eine Tastatur oder es ist ein Display. Display wollen sie ja nicht, dass es eins ist, weil es eine Tastatur-Erweiterung sein soll. Aber dann soll das nicht in den Sleep Mode gehen.
Was mich eigentlich viel, viel härter nervt, ist die Tatsache, dass mir dieses Drecks-Book ständig abschmehrt und ich wirklich täglich mindestens einen, vielleicht sogar bis zu dreimal sehe. Oh, unfortunately, Ihr MacBook ist abgestürzt. Das passiert dreimal fast am Tag. Das frage ich mich auch. Und das Gemeine war, letztens hat mir mein Kollege gezeigt, oh guck mal, ich habe hier diesen schwarzen Screen, weiße Schrift. Und ich so, Mensch, das hatte ich ja schon lange nicht mehr. Prompt hatte ich das auf diesem scheiß Schrottbook auch. Ich brauch mehr RAM.
Den hab ich wirklich seit Jahren schon nicht mehr gesehen.
Ich hab aber das rechts unten Modell mit RAM. Deswegen kann es nicht angehen.
Hast du da auch so dein altes System quasi?
Nein, nein, nein. Das ist ein komplett kleines System gewesen, weil ich, das ist mein Arbeitsnotebook, was ich von Arbeit bekommen hab, wo auch nicht...
Hast du da irgendeinen Admin, der da rumfuscht?
Die Lettie ist der dumme Admin, der da drin rumfuscht.
Dumme hab ich nicht gesagt. Also ist frisch aufgesetzt, keine komischen Tools, oder wo dein Arbeitgeber sagt, du musst dir mal das installieren.
Mein Arbeitgeber hat dieses MacBook noch nicht mal inventarisiert, glaube ich. Ich habe es erfolgreich hinbekommen, dass da kein Eigentum, der drauf steht. Das ist großartig.
Ja, wahrscheinlich morgen früh kommt da einer, das ist das Erste, was sie dir verpassen, weil du irgendeinen Hörer in der Firma hast.
Nein, es kommt ja immer mit zu mir. Also ich lasse es auch selten in der Firma.
Aus gutem Grund.
Solche Hörer werden da nicht beströmt. Nicht beströmt und nicht beladen.
Genau.
Ja, also wir warten alle sehnsüchtig.
Also 13 Zoll MacBook Pro 2015 in Vollausbau, rechts unten mit All Features on. Oder MacBook Air 2015, rechts unten All Features on. Das sind die beiden Optionen, über die ich nachdenke.
Was hast du jetzt? 2013.
2013er R 11 Zoll. Und ja, ich weiß kein Retina und so weiter. Aber mir ist das so wurscht.
Weil du es noch nicht hattest.
Weil ich es noch nicht hatte. Und weil, ja, weil ich es noch nicht hatte wahrscheinlich.
Du kommst einfach nicht mehr zurück, du kriegst die Augenkrise.
Ich hab überhaupt keinen einzigen Retina mit.
Ja, hat man ja schon mal hier. Aber deswegen, guck dir das ja nicht an. Es gibt keinen zurück.
Ich finde das nicht so dramatisch, hätte ich gesagt.
Hast du schon mal gemacht?
Na, ich hab ja das Laptop, mein Rechner, mein großer Computerscreen zu Hause, der ist nicht 4K oder so Retina-mäßig.
Außer benutze ich ja Windows-Software auf diesem Rechner und die ist natürlich immer noch nicht Retina-fähig. Sieht aus wie Windows-Software, bedient sich wie so ein Windows-Software, oder?
Hat nämlich jetzt letztens mal ein Update mit Higher Resolution.
Ja, da kommt am laufenden Metaverse und jetzt mit noch besser irgendwie Retina hier, Retina da, aber bis dann halt mal wirklich alle Widgets umgestellt sind, dass man dafür Ultraschall auch mal alles und jetzt auch mit Retina, da vergehen glaube ich noch zwei Jahre. Also ich glaube, das dauert noch. Da hat man sozusagen nicht wirklich einen Vorteil. Also ich hoffe ja, dass das irgendwann mal vielleicht kommt. Das wäre dann nochmal ein Grund. Aber mir ist der Bildschirm, also ich hab nichts gegen guten Bildschirm. Gar keine Frage. Aber ich hab halt was gegen scheiß Tastaturen und gegen bekloppte Ports.
So.
Na, die Ports sind nicht so bekloppt.
Man muss halt...
Sind halt nur neu und ungewohnt. Entsprechend nicht deiner gewohnten Infrastruktur.
Man braucht halt nur seinen Adapter-Taschen, dann ist alles super.
Aber das hast du ja jetzt auch. Es ist nur voll mit den falschen Kabeln, deswegen magst du das nicht. Aber schon alleine...
Ich hab schon damit genug Ärger.
Alleine, dass man nicht mehr gucken muss, wie rum dieser fucking Stecker reingeht, das ist es schon wert.
Ja, leider auch, wo man den Strom anschließt.
Ja, genau, du steckst einfach irgendwo rein. Und du lädst, egal in welche Seite.
Mich drüber stolzbar ist der Rechner auf dem Boden. Ich hab ja noch nicht mal MagSafe an diesen neuen Dingern.
Ja, das ist der einzige Nachteil, aber das passiert dir auch, wenn du den blöd abstellst.
Das ist der einzige Nachteil von den 10 anderen einzigen Anteilen, die wir jetzt schon aufgezählt haben.
Der einzige Nachteil von dem neuen Stecker.
Ich finde, da sind zu wenig Ports. Das ist mein größter Kritikpunkt eigentlich. Reicht nicht.
Ich finde, dass die Position auch von dem vom Klinke furchtbar ist. Ich hab so einen abgewinkelten Klinkenstecker.
Nee, Apple, das geht besser. Geht einfach besser. Habt ihr das schon besser gemacht, macht das wieder besser.
Genau, macht das mal besser.
Und den Mac Pro, den könnt ihr jetzt auch mal langsam hier...
Komm nächstes Jahr. Komm nächstes Jahr.
Na ja, kommt eh nicht das, was sie uns wünschen, glaube ich.
Das kann auch passieren.
Dann wollte ich noch was bewerben, was ich leider jetzt noch nicht zu intensiv habe testen können. Aber mein erster Eindruck ist sehr gut, weil ich die App auch schon kannte. Und zwar geht es um Podcast-Kleins. Und ich bin ja sehr wählerisch, was Podcast-Kleins betrifft, wie ihr euch denken könnt. Und nun habe ich, also... Ich bin, also es gibt für mich immer noch keinen unangefochtenen Chef im Podcast-App-Land. Und es ist ja auch einiges dazugekommen. Es gibt halt irgendwie diese Podcast-App von Apple. Ja, gern. Dann ist irgendwie Overcast total gehyped, was ich überhaupt nicht verstehen kann, weil ich finde, das sieht scheiße aus und es macht meine Schonots kaputt und macht irgendwie nichts.
Hast du etwa dem, hast du dem etwa mal eine E-Mail geschrieben?
Ob ich dem mal eine E-Mail geschrieben habe, ich habe allen Podcasts, die werden auch mal auf diesem Planeten geschrieben.
Nee, weil es ist lustig, er hat in einem ATP-Podcast ja explizit darauf hingewiesen, dass er von deutschen Podcastern angeschrieben wurde. Da musste ich so kurz an den Tim denken.
Ja, der Dialog geht ja schon länger. Also ich meine, das hat man ja glaube ich auch schon ein paar Mal, das ist vielleicht nicht mitbekommen. Dieser ganze Stichwort Don't Doubt the Germans, das war ja sein Blogpost zum Overcast 2 Neurelease, wo er dann endlich mal eingesehen hat, dass Kapitelmarken ja doch eine gute Idee sind. Und das hat er halt unter diesem Don't Doubt the Germans abgeliefert. Und das war natürlich, weil wir sprich... Wie ihr, wir und alle anderen und ihr da draußen, die ihr so zuhört, ihn halt regelmäßig mit E-Mail beballert habt mit Wo sind die Kapitelmarken? Sodass sie da auch durchaus wiederheil gefunden haben. Ich finde nicht, dass sie sonderlich gut integriert sind, aber das ist noch mal eine andere Geschichte. Mein eigentlicher Favorit im Podcast-Land bisher, mit Einschränkungen natürlich auch, aber trotz alledem fand ich schon eigentlich bisher das beste Tool war Pocketcast. Und für Pocketcast sprechen mehrere Gründer. Pocketcast ist einerseits nicht nur auf iOS, sondern auch auf Android verfügbar, wird auch auf allen Plattformen ordentlich weiterentwickelt, war auch auf Windows-Phones sogar verfügbar. Man mag es gar nicht glauben, aber ich glaube, das dürfte jetzt auch zu Ende sein, weil die Plattform ist dead. Und extra Bonus-Dreck haben sie auch ein ganz ordentliches Web-Backend. Es können natürlich viele Leute sagen, ach naja, ich höre meine Podcasts ja nur auf dem Phone, das tue ich auch. Aber Pocketcast erlaubt es eben dadurch auch, nicht nur die Podcasts zu hören im Web, sondern dass man halt auch neue Podcasts dort abonniert. Und das war für mich irgendwie immer ein Feature, dass wenn ich in einem beliebigen Rechner bin und ich sehe irgendwo Podcasts und will den abonnieren, muss ich halt nicht irgendwie mein Device in dem Moment im Zugriff haben und all diese Geschichten. Also war ich ein Pocketcast-User, aber ich habe so eine, so eine, wie sagt man?
Affäre.
So eine Affäre schon öfter gehabt, genau. Mit einer anderen App. Ich habe regelmäßig eine andere App gesehen. Wir waren uns sehr nah. Ich fand sie sehr attraktiv und wir hatten was miteinander. Und leider haben mir so ein paar ihrer Eigenschaften nicht so hoch gepasst, obwohl eigentlich alles schon so viel versprechen war. Und die Rede ist natürlich von Castro. Bitte? Fidel? Nee, einfach nur Castro, so heißt die App. Und Castro ist von so zwei Iren geschrieben. Und super top nennen die sich als Team. Ich wäre über den Planeten verteilt, der eine ist in Irland, der andere ist immer irgendwo anders. Ich hab's vergessen, ob in Amerika oder sonst irgendwo. Ist auch egal, die machen auch einen eigenen Podcast, wo sie immer sehr schön erzählen, was ihre Motivationen sind. Und sind zwei sehr angenehme Menschen, die auch, sagen wir mal, ihre ganze Strategie immer schön darlegen, auch mal diskutieren, wie so ihr Businessmodell ist und was funktioniert und was nicht. Sie sind jetzt mit Castro auch schon durch drei oder vier verschiedene Finanzierungsmodelle durch und haben das jetzt auch wieder geändert. Ich glaube, jetzt ist es tatsächlich sogar so, wenn du es runterlädst, ist es erstmal kostenlos, hat bis vor kurzem was gekostet und du kriegst dann halt extra Features über eine Subscription-Payment, was so bei 9 Euro bei Jahreszahlungen pro Jahr ist. Was für mich so unter die Schmerzgrenze von einem Euro pro Monat fällt und von daher nicht weiter schlimm ist. So, warum erwähne ich das jetzt überhaupt? Castro gibt es ja schon eine Weile. Jetzt ist die Version 3.0 rausgekommen. Wie gesagt, mit diesem Subscription-Modell. Und halleluja, wenn du jetzt dieses Subscription-Modell machst, kannst ja auch erstmal testen, dann sind auch endlich, endlich Kapitelmarken dabei. Ja, ich kann halt mit, ich kann nicht Podcasts hören, ohne einen Kapitelmarken-Interface zu haben und das hat mich immer mega gestört. Und ich wollte immer mit Castro, weil Castro ist geil. Castro ist cool und es ist nicht einfach zu erklären, warum eigentlich. Aber ich probier's trotzdem mal. Wir haben es befürchtet. Also es gibt ja in all diesen Podcasts das Problem, wie kriegst du diese Komplexität unterschiedlicher Hörgewohnheiten hin und worauf hin reduzierst du das Ganze und wie kriegst du die Interessen zusammengeführt. Und noch ein bisschen konkreter, wie fasst man auch so das, was man hören will versus das, was man jetzt nicht so sehr hören will. Diese ganze Priorisierung von was mag man lieber und was mag man weniger. Die haben alle sehr unterschiedliche Ansätze. Ich glaube, in Overcast gibt es glaube ich auch, ich weiß nicht genau wie das Feature heißt, auch so ein Priority-Mode oder Tag pro Podcast oder so was benutzt du das?
Ich benutze Overcast, aber ich weiß noch nicht, wovon du redest. Ich habe es aber jetzt auch noch nicht in der Bezahlversion, muss ich da gerade dazu sagen.
Ist auch egal, andere machen das mit Playlisten, sowas hat zum Beispiel auch Pocketcast, ja, Pocketcast, auch der Player. Also ich mag vieles an Pocketcast und ich finde es generell eigentlich ein sehr erträgliches Programm. Und du kannst halt auch immer so mehrere Episoden quasi so in deine Upnext-Diste reinwerfen, die dann aber wieder dieses düstelige Problem hat, dass die dann halt auch alle hintereinander abspielen. Das heißt, du schläfst irgendwie ein, hast zehn Sendungen irgendwie drin, was morgens auf, hast deine ganze Playlist durchgehört. Ein Sleep-Timer hilft mir. Hab ich den noch nie benutzt, weil ein Sleep-Timer, da müsste Tala mal ran, dass der auch mal wirklich merkt, wenn ich schlafe. Ich weiß noch vorher nicht, wann ich schlafe. Soll ich dann irgendwie alle fünf Minuten, ja jetzt...
Ein Männersleep-Timer war vorher einfach.
Ich dachte, deine Apple Watch checkt das.
Dann erkennt man das.
Nee, ja meine Apple Watch hab ich natürlich im Bett nicht an. Aber mein...
Auch das funktioniert nicht genau genug.
Kann ich mir gut vorstellen, aber es gibt ja diese Schlaftrecker, die so...
Alles fake, oder?
Ja, mehr fake als tatsächlich Wissenschaft.
Kann schon sein, aber wenn es irgendwie erkennt, dass ich mich weniger bewege und dann irgendwie auf Pause macht, das würde mir schon ausreichen. Das hat aber bis heute noch keiner eingebaut.
Bewegst du dich denn in meinem Podcast-Hörern besonders, wenn du im Bett liegst?
Schläft man nicht sofort ein, wenn man im Bett Podcasts hört? Ich meine, ich schlafe sogar, wenn ich im Bett Fernseh gucke.
Der Slack sagt es gerade ganz gut, einfach auf eine Stunde setzen, da sind die meisten Leute spätestens eingeschlafen. Und je nachdem, ich würde sogar behaupten, bei den meisten Männern reicht eine Viertelstunde.
Eine sehr gute.
Ich brauche länger als eine Viertelstunde zum Einschlafen, aber eine Stunde, finde ich, funktioniert ganz gut.
Eine Bibi-Blocksberg-Folge.
Eine Bibi-Blocksberg-Folge. Aber die habe ich schon durchgehört.
Ich finde es auch aus anderen Gründen doof, sofort von dem einen Podcast zum anderen überzugehen. Insbesondere, wenn du den einen schon ein bisschen angehört hast, weil der eine ist zu Ende und dann kommt sofort der nächste, in der nächsten Sekunde, spielt irgendwo weiter und du kriegst manchmal gar nicht mit, dass du jetzt einen anderen Podcast hörst. Also wie auch immer, für mich ist das alles inakzeptabel.
Können wir nicht da so Sounds zwischendurch einspielen? Können wir nicht so Sounds zwischendurch einspielen?
Das hielte ich für eine gute Wahl, aber das habe ich bisher noch nirgendswo gesehen.
Die haben gar keine Fantasie oder auch, dass man sagt, hier alle Viertelstunde soll so ein ganz kleines so nebenbei kommen im Hören, dass man einfach kurz dann das Telefon schüttelt oder so, dann eine Passe drückt, damit es dann wieder eine Viertelstunde verlängert.
Das ist nämlich auch ein guter Punkt, dass das Ding sozusagen immer früh stehen bleibt, wenn keine Bewegung mehr da ist und dann musst du nur kurz so nochmal irgendwie auf die Matratze hauen oder so. Müsste man mal mit experimentieren. Okay, das Schlafproblem ist jetzt nicht mein Hauptproblem, warum ich jetzt Castro so mag. Castro hat nämlich zwei Konzepte eigentlich oder drei Arten und Weisen auf deine Podcasts zu schauen. Das hilft mit mehreren Dingen gleichzeitig. Also zunächst einmal gibt es die Inbox. Nein, doch! Und sie ist ein bisschen was anderes, als man vielleicht denken würde. Also tatsächlich, es ist so schwierig zu erklären, warte mal.
Das ist der Zeit, mach ganz in Ruhe.
Ich machs nochmal anders. Also alle Podcasts, die du abonniert hast, erscheinen im Archiv. Es gibt einen Button unten im Menü und so richtig so ein kleiner, wie nennt man den, so ein Menü-Bar am Boden. So, da hast du den Archiv-Button und da siehst du quasi eine Liste deiner Podcasts. Da sind sie sozusagen archiviert, da kannst du drauf zugreifen, kannst du irgendwie Episoden dir raussuchen, wenn du das möchtest, etc. Und kannst ja auch eine Listen-Historie anschauen und kannst ja anschauen, welche Sternchen du verteilst hast, etc. Das ist sozusagen so die finale Ablage, da liegt erstmal alles drin. Dann kannst du eben für, entweder als Default für alle oder eben auch nur ausgewählt für manche Podcasts sagen, wenn hier eine neue Folge kommt, tu die in die Inbox. Die Inbox ist aber nicht da, wo du hörst, sondern die Inbox zeigt dir sozusagen nur an what's new und das ist so mehr so eine ausgewählte Timeline von neun Episoden, eben podcastübergreifend, wobei du da oben auch relativ schnell das auf einen Podcast reduzieren kannst, weil du oben so eine kleine Liste von Icons hast mit einer Zahl, wie viele Episoden jetzt in der Inbox davon vertreten sind, sodass sie eben auch schnell mal in dieser Inbox deinen Fokus auf einen Podcast richten kannst, wenn du das möchtest. Aber das eigentliche, von wo du weghörst, ist die Queue. Und die Queue wiederum ist quasi die Vorauswahl, das will ich auch wirklich hören und da kannst du es dann gleich an den Anfang oder gleich ans Ende werfen. Also du kannst quasi für jeden Podcast sagen, bitte archivieren, weil den habe ich zwar abonniert, aber den höre ich gerade nicht, den höre ich nur auf Zuruf oder auf Nachschlagen oder warum auch immer, so den will ich nur verfolgen, aber ich will ihn auch nicht deabonnieren. Das ist oft bei Podcast-Klient so, dass wenn du was abonnierst, dann hast du irgendwie auch so ein Commitment und dann drängt sich das Ding sofort in deine Aufmerksamkeit rein. Hier ein Podcast, den du seit drei Monaten verfolgst, der dich aber eigentlich nur aus bestimmten Aspekten, die nicht weiter Not tun, erklärt zu werden, interessiert, trotzdem mischt er sich die ganze Zeit mit deinem Primär-Content und du musst es immer rausfiltern. Und das fällt bei Castro erstmal weg, weil du kannst halt sagen, ok, ist zwar abonniert, liegt da, ist ein Archiv, kann ich suchen, kann ich finden, all diese Dinge, aber stört erstmal nicht. Und dann wählst du dir die aus, die für dich überhaupt so die Kandidaten sind oder die du vielleicht etwas näher beobachten willst und die lässt du in deine Inbox treufeln. Und aus der Inbox kannst du was in die Queue werfen, aber die Sachen, die dich halt besonders interessieren, kannst du auch gleich in die Queue werfen, nach dem Motto, höre ich sowieso immer. Und dann kannst du aber auch noch unterscheiden mit ganz am Anfang oder ans Ende der Queue. Also sozusagen wirklich so deine Hot, so was wie Freak Show zum Beispiel, also was jeder sofort runterladen und sofort hören will, so das könnte man damit eben wunderbar machen. Ja und das gibt's jetzt und vielleicht ist das für euch eine Option. Es gibt natürlich auch eine Sache, die noch fehlt, die Pocketcast hat, die mir sehr sehr sehr wichtig ist, die leider hier nicht drin ist und wo ich jetzt anfangen werde mal wieder auf die Jungs einzuprügeln, dass sie das doch bitte mal einbauen, so ein Pagefeeds, dass man hier mal so ein komplettes Sendungsarchiv auch hat. Das verstehe ich nicht, warum das nicht schon längst alle eingebaut haben.
Aber das hat doch zum Beispiel Overcast, ne?
Ne, Overcast hat das natürlich auch nicht. Overcast wehrt sich ja gegen alles. Gegen Podlabs, Simple Chapters, gegen Pagefeeds, gegen ordentliche Shownotes. Wie war's? Würdest du mir jetzt nicht sagen, dass Overcast das eingebaut hat? Und niemand Bescheid gesagt hat.
Wenn ich da auf All gehe, sehe ich, was ich noch nicht gehört habe, logischerweise.
Bei dem Podcast weiß ich aber nicht, was da im Feed ist. Da musst du mal mit CRE ausprobieren. Wenn du CRE abonnierst und da kommen alle Folgen, dann hast du Pagefeeds.
Aber ich dachte, das hat jetzt Kapitelmarken. Kapitelmarken hat das ja. Nee, aber du hast gerade gesagt, Podlove, Simple, Chapters.
Das ist das andere Problem. Wo kommen die Kapitelinformationen her?
Aus Schlimmpfhausen, bitte sehr.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen sind halt alle der Meinung, das müsste irgendwie aus den Medien-Dateien herauskommen, obwohl es lustigerweise am schwierigsten ist, die da überhaupt reinzukriegen. Durch Awphonic und NoTools ist es jetzt ein bisschen einfacher geworden, aber es ist einfach mega schwierig, die da reinzubekommen und trotzdem ist das irgendwie für alle die Quelle. Overcast holt sich das halt aus MP3 und ich glaube auch aus MP4-Files. Ich muss gerade ein bisschen nachdenken, weil ich weiß bei Pocketcast ist es zum Beispiel so, dass sie halt zum Beispiel auf Android, dass nur sie sich aus MP3 rausholen, aber nicht aus MP4. Was ich auch verstehen kann, weil es ist ja undokumentiert und du kriegst es unter iOS quasi vom Betriebssystem dagereicht, da passt quasi das Betriebssystem das aus den Files raus für dich. Und bei MP3 kannst du halt selber machen, weil es halt ordentlich standardisiert und breit unterstützt. Aber ich hab halt oft so Leute, die sagen, warum hast du denn keine Kapitelmarken in deinem Podcast? Da sag ich, ich hab in jeder Datei Kapitelmarken überall immer, immer, immer. So, nur du benutzt halt Pocketcasts auf Android und hast aber den MP4-Feed abonniert und deswegen geht's nicht. Und die Idee von den Simple Chapters ist ja, ah, eine Textinformation mit wenig Overhead, die man einfach parsen möchte. Warum nicht einfach in den Feed tun, wo der Feed ja sowieso schon geparsst wird? Das ist ja das Absurde. Also diese Dinger parsen ja die ganze Zeit XML und pflügen sich durch diese Metadaten durch. Und wir schreiben sie einfach dazu, einfach eine kleine Klammer auf. Ach, hier ist übrigens die Kapitel. Name, Zeit, Name, Zeit, Name, Zeit, Name, Zeit, Klammer zu, fertig. Aufwand, das zu parsen, sein Programm einzubauen, Null. Also das kann mir einfach keiner erzählen, dass das irgendwie ein Aufwand ist oder so. Aber irgendwie haben sie sich, weil das ist ja aus Deutschland und so. Und weißt du, Geier, was aus Deutschland alles so kommt?
Nichts Gutes, das wissen wir. Aber, wenn ich dich jetzt richtig verstehe und du möchtest die Timeline haben, muss ich dir, also ich hab jetzt mal einen der Podcasts genommen, fängt bei Folge 0 an.
Wo bist du jetzt?
Bei Overcast. Und wenn ich da in den Tab gehe, alle, sie gibt's sogar noch, genau, kann ich mir dann halt sortieren lassen, da sind wirklich alle Folgen drin aus dem Podcast. Aber was ich bei CAE sehe, da hast du scheinbar bei Folge 150, 160, 159. Genau, war ein Bruch drin. Bis dahin geht's definitiv.
Ja, es sind nicht mehr Folgen im Feed, weil wenn ich alle Folgen in den Feed reintue, dann explodieren alle Podcast-Apps. Das hab ich schon einmal gemacht durch einen Fehler, da ist der Gesamtpodcast Deutschland hat gebrannt.
Ja, dann schafft es aber zum Beispiel The Daily mit ihren 300 noch was, die hier grad drin sind.
Weil die ja auch nur 5 Zeilen Shownotes haben und nicht solche Compendien und Glossare mitliefern wie ich. Das ist doch das Problem.
Oh, sie benutzen es falsch.
Ich habe Metadaten, die sind umfangreich und voll. Das war bestimmt gerade in der Lautstärke, wie bei Office Space, wo der Anrufbeantworter so über den Boden liegt.
Aber du hast auch mehrspurige Aufnahmen.
Die Hörer haben kein mehrspuriges Gehör.
Ach, du lieferst das nicht so aus?
Auf jeden Fall habe ich schon vergessen, was ich sagen wollte.
Ja, das war der Plan.
Du hinterhältiger Saboteur.
Nein, um es kurz zu machen, würde ich alle meine Feats, Freak Show, alle Sendungen da rein tun, 218 Folgen. Dann wäre der Feed mehrere Megabyte groß. Wenn ich das einschalten würde, kannst du wirklich so 21, 22 mitzählen. Und 10 Minuten später geht es auf Twitter los.
Was ist mit meinem Podcast?
Das mag sich ein bisschen geändert haben, die Situation, weil so viele auf Backend-Parsing und so weiter gegangen sind, aber auch da ist halt einiges explodiert. Also ich kann das ja verstehen, und ich würde das ja auch gerne tun. Und ich will das ja auch machen. Nur es gibt so einen einfachen Weg, das zu umgehen. Indem man halt Page Fees macht. Das ist ein RFC, steht genau drin, wie es geht. Steht einfach ein Link auf das nächste Ding, passt man dann weiter. Und alles gut. Pocketcars hat das drin. Kann mir keiner erzählen, warum die anderen das nicht auch einbauen sollten. Ich werde die da schon hinkriegen. Ich tritt die so lange, bis sie...
Ich würde mal kurz die Prioritäten neu setzen wollen. Bevor du hier diese Podcast-Hörleur öffnest, kannst du doch erstmal Apple schreiben? Naja, wegen den Notebooks und damit wir wieder bessere Hardware haben. Ich finde, das Problem ist Größe.
Ja, gut, das kann man jetzt nicht so miteinander vergleichen. Auf jeden Fall Castro, top. Geiles Ding. Ich finde es einfach von der Usability her super. Testet es gerne mal aus, ist nett auszuprobieren und mir gefällt das. Und wer jetzt nicht aufs Archiv zugreifen möchte, der wäre nämlich bei Pocked Cars besser zu Hause, ist Castro durchaus eine Option. Aber ich werde mir demnächst auch nochmal mehr, jetzt habe ich mal wieder ein bisschen Mut gefasst, mal wieder so kleines, komplett neu zu initialisieren und durchzutesten, werde ich mir vielleicht mal ein bisschen mehr anschauen.
Fängst an zu laufen, testest wieder neue Podcasts. Das klingt ja nach einer ganz neuen Lebensabschnittsperiode. Ein neues Leben fängt an.
Jetzt, wo ich Buchhaltung durchgespielt habe.
Ist vorbei mit Buchhaltung, ja?
Dann können wir das jetzt angehen mit dem Berlin-Marathon.
Lauft ihr dann bei mir vorbei?
Jawohl, mit Inlandskates.
Bei mir auch.
Wie, in der Linienstraße noch nicht vorbei?
Du willst mich jetzt on air verpflichten?
Genau, ich will dich hier on air verpflichten.
Naja, abgesehen davon, dass das Wochenende ein bisschen schwierig ist für mich. Grundsätzlich spricht aber nichts dagegen. Aber soweit war man glaube ich schon mal in der Diskussion.
Na jetzt haben wir es ja quasi verpflichtend gemacht und die Fans werden uns natürlich anjubeln.
Ich werde auch von meinem kleinen Austritt zu winken.
Wir brauchen noch Freak Show-Fanchen. Kannst du das mal auf deine Merchandise-Liste aufnehmen? Ja Puschel, Pom-Pom-Puschel finde ich ist so ein bisschen... Tala, mir kommt die Pom-Pom-Puschel.
Nehm ich.
Ich pushe dir zu.
Das finde ich cool.
Ich möchte übrigens an dieser Stelle auch nochmal Werbung für ein Ding machen. Denn ich habe ja, wie ich gerade schon meinte, so mein Audio-Equipment immer so einmal durchgecycelt und habe das auch wieder mit reverb.com gemacht. Weil ich wurde letztens bei Ebay-Kleinanzeigen beschissen. Das erste Mal in meinem Leben, dass meine Gutgläubigkeit und meine positive Grundeinstellung eiskalt ausgenutzt wurde. Ich habe halt was gekauft und es klang auch alles so total einvernehmlich und freundlich und dann kam halt aber nichts. Und jetzt habe ich diese ganze Rennerei da am hacken und dann dachte ich mir, okay, ich benutze das Kleineanzeigen nicht mehr und mache das jetzt alles über reverb.com und das ist auch nach wie vor so, dass jetzt im Vergleich zu Ebay oder Ebay Kleineanzeigen auf reverb.com vielleicht weniger los ist an Material, aber das was los ist, das ist 1A. Also die Verkäufer Experience ist großartig, die Käufer Experience ist großartig und die machen halt auch wirklich dieses Käuferschutz oder Treuhandsystem sowieso per Default, haben das Tracking deiner Pakete gleich mit eingebaut und Bezahlstatus hier und da und sowieso ist einfach super. Also ich habe jetzt in den letzten zwei Wochen all das was ich verkaufen wollte da verkauft bekommen und keine Querelen und ich kann euch das nur sagen, also für Audio-Equipment, Musikinstrumente etc. macht das auf reverb.com. Sagt allen euren Freunden, dass sie das benutzen sollen und lasst dieses Scheiß Ebay-Kleinanzeigen, sorry Roddy, in Ruhe, das ist wirklich eine Drecksplattform.
Aber du weißt schon, ab wann die Probleme, die du bei Ebay-Kleinanzeigen hast, auch bei Reverb haben wirst? Wenn das alle anfangen zu benutzen?
Nein, eben nicht. Weil die ja von vorne, also bei Ebay-Kleinanzeigen da ist ja nur, ich schreibe eine Einzeige rein und wie dann der Kauf zustande kommt und wie das Geld hin und her wandert und so, das ist ja quasi privat ausgehandelt.
Das heißt, die vermitteln nur, aber die übernehmen das Management nicht bei Tala.
Genau, keinerlei Haftung, keinerlei Service, etc. reverb.com, wie schwer ist das? reverb.com, hier, warte einen Moment, HTTPS, doppelpunkt, doppelseitig, ich krieg da auch noch alles dafür. Genau, die machen, wie gesagt bei reverb.com, da hast du halt ein Service-Team, wenn du denen was schreibst. Klar, ihr Support sitzt auch in Amerika, das heißt, es kann ja mal noch einen halben Tag dauern, aber die kümmern sich tatsächlich und die machen halt so einen treuen Service. Das heißt, das Geld kommt jetzt, ne? Genau, also die gucken dann halt auch über die ganzen Versandapis, ist das Paket angekommen und solange da keiner widerspricht, dann, sobald es angekommen ist, dass irgendwas kaputt ist, kriegst du dann dein Geld auch ausgezahlt. Und, ja, die nehmen, glaube ich, auch weniger Gebühren als Ebay tatsächlich. Und, ja, da gibt's auch, also auch der ganze Modus ist einfach viel angenehmer, weil bei Ebay ist es ja so, dass deine Anzeige immer so eine bestimmte Zeit nur drin ist. Und bei Reverb ist die Anzeige potenziell auch für immer drin, so wie bei Kleinanzeigen.
Das bräuchte es eigentlich mal so für Computer-Stuff. Man hat so viel alte Hardware, die es einfach zu schade ist, wegzuschmeißen, aber man kann jetzt auch nicht drei Jahre irgendwo bei Ebay drin stehen lassen. Aber so, dass man immer sagt, hier, ich hab all noch die geilen Sachen hier, meldet euch irgendwann, wenn ihr das mal genau gebrauchen könnt.
Also, ich find's super und ich wünsche mir, dass viel mehr Leute in Deutschland das nutzen. Das kommt halt aus Amerika und der amerikanische Markt ist halt natürlich da viel größer, aber ich benutze das halt immer so, wenn ich nach Dingen suche, da kann man sagen, ich will Angebote, die nach Deutschland schippen und die aus der European Union kommen. Also, du kannst halt sozusagen From-on-to-Filter setzen und das ist dann ganz angenehm, aber potentiell kannst du eben, wenn du Angebote reinstellst, sagen, ich schippe überall da und dahin und dann tauchst du dann in den entsprechenden Filtern auf. Aber mein Standardfilter ist, kommt aus der EU, geht nach Deutschland und dann bisher wirklich beste Erfahrungen gemacht. So, kleine Werbeveranstaltung vorbei, aber wirklich aus Überzeugung. Ich habe da, glaube ich, in den letzten zwei Wochen 2000 Euro eingenommen durch Rausschirmung. Ich hatte die gleichen Anzeigen auch noch bei eBay und auch bei eBay-Kleinanzeigen drin. Und bei ReWrub ging es tatsächlich auch in dem Fall schneller. Aber es lag vielleicht auch eben daran, dass die Hardware jetzt auch nicht der letzte Grappelscheiß war.
Mich würde sowas ja mal interessieren für näherelevante Sachen halt auch. Ich habe halt super viele alte Stoffe, die ich nicht mehr brauche, aber das geht auf Ebay-Kleimanzeigen halt super schlecht weg. Und halt auch alte Schnittmuster, wo ich weiß, habe ich mal aus irgendeiner dämlichen Idee gekauft, welche ich in meinem Leben nicht nähen. Das dämlichste von allen Schnittmustern habe ich in der Tat verkauft bekommen. Da war ich ein bisschen schockiert, aber es war halt gerade Karnevalszeit.
Dann musst du immer zu Karneval reinsetzen.
Ja, vielleicht.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich auch, warum die Plattform so gut funktioniert, weil sie sich halt wirklich auf dieses Audiomusik-Thema spezialisiert haben und diesen ganzen anderen Müll mit Autoteilen oder alte gammelige Teppiche, wo die Katze schon dreimal raufgepingelt hat.
Das war der Shopping-Teil?
Das war der Shopping-Teil. Und dann hätte ich noch ein Anliegen an die Welt da draußen. Vor allen Dingen an die nerdlichen Zuhörer. Sprecht mit euren Freunden, die sich nicht so mit Nerd-Themen auskennen, über SEO, bevor es jemand anderes tut. SEO ist Search Engine Optimization. Und ich war ganz schockiert vor kurzem, dass...
Du hast unsere Sendung hier gehört? Oder warst du dabei sogar?
Nee, da war ich nicht dabei.
Wir hatten eine ganz tolle Freak Show zu diesem Thema.
Dann hör euch die gleich als erstes Mal an.
Wir hatten dann SEO als Gast. Aber fast?
Nein, fast ist aber nicht das Gleiche.
Was hat er denn gemacht?
Sebastian Jabosch war da und er ist Social Media-Spezialist. Das ist sozusagen seine Domäne. Zero ist da eher so ein Nebeneffekt.
Genau, es geht auch eher darum, dass ich angesprochen wurde von einem gemeinsamen Bekannten, Details später, dass irgendwie die Angetraute gerade ein ganz großes Problem hätte, weil sie hätte jemanden beauftragt, die Webseite SEO-mäßig aufzubürsten. Der Effekt war eher das Gegenteil. Und weil sie daraufhin nicht so einverstanden war, damit die doch recht horrende Rechnung zu bezahlen, hat der Werteherr daraufhin die ganze Webseite komplett aus dem Google-Index gelöscht, weil er den Zugang zu allen Accounts hatte. Und dann hat sie das erst im Nachhinein erfahren, weil überhaupt gar nichts mehr auf der Webseite ging. Und dann hab ich, ich war erstens ein bisschen schockiert, dass es wirklich immer noch gibt, dass es so Buden gibt, die sich nur auf SEO konzentrieren. Und zweitens, dass dann auch eben Leute auch immer noch heutzutage da so diesen, sag ich mal, Leuten dann auf den Leim gehen. Es gibt bestimmt auch total super SEO-Optimierer. Ich würde aber sagen, braucht man eigentlich gar nicht. Und wenn ihr auch schon mal dachtet, hey, vielleicht sollte ich mal so einen SEO-Menschen engagieren oder so, fragt lieber den Nerd eures Vertrauens, ob er oder sie nicht vielleicht euch ein paar nützliche Tipps geben kann. Weil das Ding ist ja das, was man so früher mit SEO gemacht hat. Irgendwie so diese ganzen Keywords-Spam im HTML oder so eine Link-Farmen oder Leute anschreiben, hey, kannst du auf meine Seite verlinken, dann verlinke ich auch auf deine Seite.
Das hieß es schon bei Blade Runner, hieß Interlink.
Genau, ja, dieser ganze Krempel. Also das ist ja, warum Google eigentlich auch so erfolgreich geworden ist, weil die ja sozusagen sich darum kümmern oder bemühen, mit dieser Suchmaschine diese ganzen Bescheissereien quasi auszuschließen. Beziehungsweise sogar zu bestrafen. Ja, und das, was so früher so dann die Leute irgendwie ganz viel gemacht haben, das ist ja heute gar nicht mehr wirklich relevant. Und das Schöne ist ja noch, Google und alle anderen Suchmaschinen sagen einem sogar noch, was man tun muss, damit man möglichst freundlich für ihre Bots ist. Ja, da gibt es bei Google die Web-Developer-Tools, wo man irgendwie Feedback bekommt. Es gibt irgendwie 1.003 gratis Webseiten, wo man seine URL eintippen kann. Und dann kriegt man genau gesagt, ey, du hast auf deiner Webseite null Text, keine semantische Struktur, bei dir fehlt das Titel-Tag, das Description-Tag oder was auch immer. Oder deine Bilder haben keine alternativen Texte. Und dann muss man das vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen nachlesen, aber dann hakt man diese ganzen Punkte ab und dann ist man eigentlich schon ganz gut dabei. Und ja, das Hauptproblem von den Seiten, die ich jetzt in letzter Zeit mal wieder mir angucken musste, in den Kulissen ist tatsächlich auch das Semantik-Web und so. Das ist ja auch immer noch in weiten Teilen nicht angekommen. Es gibt immer noch Leute, die ihre Webseiten mit... Es heißt heutzutage Adobe Muse. Das hieß früher Go Life und Dreamweaver. Wir kennen alle noch diese What you see is what you get Web-Editor. Heutzutage machen die kein zugemülltes HTML mehr, sondern die machen einfach quasi eine leere Seite und machen alles mit JavaScript hinterher. Ich hab so zwei Muse-generierten Seiten gesehen. Da war halt Null echte Information in dem HTML. Alles wurde mit JavaScript reingepfrumpft. Und dann fragt man sich halt, ja, wieso ist denn meine Seite jetzt nicht irgendwie so gut zu finden? Oder warum hat Google die jetzt nicht so toll indiziert? Ja, weil da nix drinsteht, wenn da Google draufguckt. Oder auch so Sachen wie die Basics, wie diese Headline-Elemente, da gibt es halt die größte Headline und die kleinste Headline. Und wenn man die halt so bunt miteinander mischt, dann weiß halt die Maschine nicht, ja, was ist jetzt das Wichtige? Wenn du jetzt da unten mittendrin irgendwo ein H1 machst, dann ist das wohl der Titel jetzt der Webseite, ne? Oder alles nur mit Dips und keine Paragraphen und so weiter. Ihr kennt das ja eigentlich alle. Also deswegen, wenn ihr Freunde habt, die sich Webseiten klicken und so, und dann redet mal mit denen. Einfach so eine kleine kurze Semantik-Webberatung oder Massage. Kurz mal sagen, was das so auf sich hat mit so ein bisschen Struktur im HTML. Dann kann man schon ganz viel Geld sparen und Frust sparen und ja, dann stirbt dieses SEO-Thema vielleicht irgendwo.
Freunde haben schlechtes Sehen. Ignoriert das nicht, sprecht sie an.
Ich dachte gerade, das Fenster ist zugegangen, aber es ist ja offen, es ist irgendwie warm. Ja, ne, also wirklich. Ich hab jetzt in letzter Zeit wieder mal mehr mit so der Frontend-Seite von diesem Internet zu tun und bin doch schockiert, dass es im 21. Jahrhundert sich nicht viel geändert hat. Nicht viel geändert hat leider, ja.
Ich hab auch noch eine lustige Anekdote. Und zwar eine aus Mainz, vielleicht eine aus Karlsruhe, mal gucken. Und zwar, ich war in Mainz. Und warum war ich noch mal da? Ah ja, wegen...
Fußball?
Kommst schon ganz durcheinander mit den ganzen Veranstaltungen.
Isaac.
Ich glaube, du warst nicht in Mainz?
Nein, ich war in Mainz, nein, nein.
Karlsruhe.
Ich war in Mainz. Ich bin so viel rumgetingelt in dieser Gegend da, Würzburg, Pipapo, das war... Isaac war natürlich in Würzburg. Egal. Na ja, auf jeden Fall habe ich dann in dem Rahmen ein paar lustige Leute besucht, die in so einem ura ura uralten Haus, angeblich dem ältesten Haus, Wohnhaus in Mainz überhaupt, also so richtig so das älteste Gebäude, wo Menschen drin wohnen, wie eine spacige WG am Start haben. Und wir liefen da rein. Das hatte so ein bisschen so was, wie die Seabase kennt. So den Touch hat das so ein bisschen, wohl auch viel gebaut. Aber auf jeden Fall ist das ganz unterhaltsam. Und dann gab es auch ein paar interessante Regale mit Zeug. Und wir zogen irgendwie so munter irgendwelche Manuals so aus dem Regal. Und auf einmal fiel mir so eine Fiebe in die Hand und ich sah sofort, was es war. Es war nämlich ein Buch, was sehr viel mit meiner persönlichen Vergangenheit zu tun hat. Heißt Handbuch für Hacker. Und das ist eine wirklich interessante Informationssammlung, die noch älter ist als die Hackerbibel vom CCC. Also wir reden von 1984. Die ist sozusagen in dem Jahr, glaube ich, oder 83, 83, 84 in dem Zeitraum erschienen.
Und das Ding da ist von?
83, 84.
Die kam danach, sagt das, das wäre das Datum.
Das Handbuch für Hacker war sozusagen noch ein bisschen eher da. Und während die Hackerbibel ja auch sehr, wie soll ich sagen, sehr breit kulturell aufgestellt war, eigentlich mehr so ein Kulturzeitdokument, was letztlich war mit vielen interessanten Texten und Abdrucken von der Tab etc. war das Handbuch für Hacker sehr praktisch angelegt. Das heißt nämlich Handbuch für Hacker und andere Freaks. Und kam als Loseblattsammlung in so einem kleinen Schul, den A5-Hefter daher. Und war im Prinzip mega innovativ, weil mit dem Kauf des Buches hast du auch gleich drei sogenannte Nachlieferungen mit erworben. Die dann später nachgereicht wurden. Das heißt, die Leute, die es gekauft haben und ihre Adresse hinterlassen haben, haben dann irgendwann ein Addendum oder ein Erata zugeschickt bekommen mit einzelnen Seiten, mit einer pfiffig ausgedachten hierarchischen Seitennummerierung, sodass du quasi auch nachträglich irgendwo noch Seiten mit einer korrekten Nummerierung nachschieben konntest. Und ja, das fand dann halt auch statt. Warum finde ich das jetzt so toll? Also erstmal ist das irgendwie, ich sag gleich mal, was der Inhalt ist, aber für mich persönlich war es halt sehr interessant, weil der Mensch, der das eben gemacht hat, der Jürgen Schaller, war halt damals ein extrem guter Freund von mir und im Prinzip so ein bisschen mein Gateway in diese ganze Computerwelt. Und das war so ziemlich das allererste, was ich überhaupt da gemacht habe, als ich aufgeschlagen bin. Ich habe irgendwie die Cover von diesen Büchern auf diese Heftchen drauf geklebt. Und auf einmal hielt ich nach 30 Jahren wieder so ein Teil in der Hand und war ganz entzückt. Naja, habe ich es mir gleich ausgeliehen und gescannt. Ich werde gleich das PDF mal in die Welt werfen. Und es ist wirklich sehr interessant. Ich kann euch das ja mal hier so ein bisschen rumreichen. Im Prinzip ist das so eine Fiebe, die quasi alle Informationen zusammenträgt, die man so Anfang der 80er Jahre brauchte, um irgendwie DFÜ zu machen.
Ich erinnere mich ganz, ganz...
Tala?
Ich erinnere mich an was ganz grob, aber ich weiß nicht.
Datenfernübertragung.
Ich wollte ganz sagen, dass... Ich sah es in einem Fenster vor mir, weil man sich mit einem Modem wahrscheinlich irgendwo connectiert hat. Genau. Da war ich aber nicht ganz sicher, ob der...
Oder warst du schon ganz weit vorne? Normalerweise Akustikkoppler und so.
Ja gut, dafür bin ich wahrscheinlich dann wirklich ein bisschen zu jung.
Das kann schon sein. Also, ich meine, kennenlernen kann man das trotzdem. Es gibt ja sicherlich auch noch welche, aber man findet oft schon auch gar keine kompatiblen Telefonhörer mehr.
Man kann sagen, dass diese Hacker-Bibli... Handbuchverhacker. Handbuchverhacker ist älter als du.
Ich weiß.
Auf jeden Fall... Das war die Realität. Also wenige Leute haben das überhaupt gemacht. Es hieß DFÜ. Das war der Begriff, mit dem in Deutschland zumindest das quasi dieses ganze Netzwesen tituliert wurde. Man hat DFÜ gemacht, da hatten Fernübertragungen, weil das war für sich genommen schon mal was unglaublich Aufregendes. Und wenn man damals ein 300 Bit pro Sekunde Modem sein eigen nannte, gehörte man schon zu totalen Avantgarde.
Huckel riecht gerade am Papier.
Das ist nicht Modem hieß bei 300 Bit, sondern Akustikkoppler.
Nein, ich rede ja von einem Modem. Also es gab natürlich auch Modems aus den USA, 300 Bit pro Sekunde Modem. Und in Deutschland hatten bloß in der Regel alle Akustikkoppler, weil ja die galvanische Verkopplung verboten war. Genau.
Und Datafon S21D.
Genau, das Datafon S21D oder eben auch das Datenklo, das CCC, war ja auch so ein Projekt. Das stand dann halt auch in der Hackerbibel, also quasi der erste deutsche Bausatz für einen Akustikkoppler, der eben sich aus Einzelteilen aus dem Sanitärfachhandel zusammensetzte und deswegen halt Datenklo hieß. Das war so die Zeit. Also ich hab ernsthaft in 80er Jahren bei mir zu Hause gesessen mit einem Rechner, C64 hatte diesen Akustikkoppler, alle mussten schweigen. Man rief halt, also man wählte auf einer W-Scheibe eine Telefonnummer an. Hörte, dass die Maschine sich auf der anderen Seite meldete mit Grie, Reflöte.
So wie ein Faxhals ungefähr.
Ja genau und nur noch nicht so sophisticated. Ja und dann steckst du halt den Hörer in diese Muffen rein und wartest darauf, dass halt irgendwie die beiden Maschinen und musst deine eigene Software sagen, so jetzt hier sende mal, weil die hat ja auch keine Vorstellung davon, dass jetzt ein Call angefangen hat, weil davon wusste das ja nix, das ist ja nur so ein Audio-Interface, wo Töne rüberkommen. Ja und dann musste man halt die ganze Zeit ruhig sein, weil wenn man während der Datenübertragung liessen musste, dann war halt irgendwie alles weg. Naja, auf jeden Fall das Handbuch für Hacker trägt zusammen. Telefonnummern von Mailboxen. Das ist im Prinzip ein vollständiges Verzeichnis der deutschen DfÜ-Infrastruktur. Also quasi nach Städten. Ich werfe mal hier für den Chat mal das PDF. Habe ich jetzt lange noch auf die Folter gespannt. Das PDF mal hier in den Slack rein. Da kommt es auch schon ganz exklusiv für euch. Ich mach das natürlich nachher noch auf den Server und in die Show Notes.
Da kommt nichts.
Das lädt gerade hoch. Das ist ein bisschen größer, der Scan. Das sind ein paar Seiten geworden. 73 MB, das muss ja auch erstmal weg. Und natürlich dann eben, was damals auch noch ein Thema war. Man hat ja nicht nur Computer-Mailboxen, also BBS auf Englisch, in Deutschland hat man es einfach Mailbox genannt. Also einzelne Systeme, die in Deutschland eben ein oder wenn es schon richtig wild wurde, sogar zwei Modems gleichzeitig betrieben haben. Aber in der Regel war immer nur einer gleichzeitig online. Also immer der Reihe nach, jeder nur ein Kreuz. Und dann hat man halt irgendwo angerufen, hat seine Nachrichten an jemanden geschrieben, die wurden dann da abgespeichert. Und dann ging man wieder raus aus der Leitung, da konnte der nächste rein. Und Systeme, die halt mit zwei oder vier Leitungen sogar dann klar kamen später, die waren schon total wild und abenteuerlich. Und da hatte man schon dieses Online-Gefühl. Oh, ich tippe hier was auf meinen Bildschirm und das, was die andere Person tippt, das erscheint im gleichen Moment unfassbar. Ja, das Handbuch für Elka ist wirklich interessant, wenn man da mal so durchblättert, was da so für Dinge Realität waren. Also es ist eine interessante Zeitreise, war es dann für mich auch. Ja, und das ist jetzt meines Wissens das erste Mal, dass dieses Ding irgendwie überhaupt digital das Netz gesehen hat. Ich habe das PDF so gemacht, das sind A5-Seiten und wenn man sich das im PDF-Viewer anschaut, dann empfehle ich mal, den beidseitigen, also so ein Two-Page-View aufzumachen, weil dann hat man das quasi so vor sich, wie man das in diesem Ringordner vor sich hat.
Das ist unscharf.
Aber ist nicht der Scan jetzt dein Beamer, oder?
Ja, ich müsste es noch mal hinzufügen, aber das habe ich jetzt irgendwie nicht. Irgendwie kämpft hier gerade das...
Na, der macht das wahrscheinlich gerade live, oder? Dein Spotlight zieht sich gerade aus dem PDF rein, beim ersten Eröffnen?
Nö, das liegt ja schon ein paar Wochen. Naja, also auf jeden Fall auch so ein paar Instruktionstexte, was man denn so gebraucht hat damals. Wenn man sich das mal so durchliest, dann kann man vielleicht erahnen, was das damals für ein Schmerz war, hier überhaupt irgendwelche Daten durch die Gegend zu bringen. Aber dafür eben auch so detaillierte Erklärungen der ganzen Frequenzrealitäten. Ich find's super.
Damals in Klondike.
Genau, damals in Klondike. Ist halt hier alte Scheiße von alten Leuten. Aber ist ja manchmal ganz interessant.
Apropos alte Scheiße, angeblich ist Mac OS X genauso alt wie Classic Mac OS jetzt. Heute.
Wird langsam Zeit für eine Ablösung.
So, während Letty und Tala noch begeistert im Handbuch für Hacker blättern. Wollte ich nochmal, oder habt ihr Anmerkungen? Nee, ihr schaut erstmal. Dann war ich noch in Karlsruhe. Letty, du warst ja auch da, ne?
Genau.
Genau, auf der GPN. Das war ja kurz nach unserer letzten Sendung und ich hab im Blogbuch Netzpolitik schon mal kurz was dazu gesagt. Ist eine coole Veranstaltung gewesen. Kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Ich höre auch nur Gutes.
Ich war sehr angetan, weil mir das mal wieder als Gesamtpaket sehr gut gefallen hat. Also man merkt, dass da Erfahrung ist, man merkt, dass da Tradition schon aufgebaut wurde. Ich meine, das ist jetzt auch die 18. sozusagen offiziell, zählung nach. Auch wenn, glaube ich, eine davon nur so pro forma war. Schöne Location, wunderbar gebaut, alles mit Stil, schöne Musik, geile Lounge. Irgendwie alles hat gepasst.
Sind die eigentlich immer im gleichen Ort?
Na, die ist jetzt in den letzten zehn Jahren da gewesen. Und hat sich, wenn ich das richtig sehe...
Also stabiler vom Ort als der Kongress.
Ja, kann man so sagen. Aber ist halt auch schon die dritte Location. Aber das läuft da ganz gut und noch passt die Location auch zur Nachfrage. Also diesmal kamen wohl mehr Leute als sonst, als bisher und hat aber trotzdem wunderbar gepasst. Also die Räumlichkeiten sind wirklich toll. Also das ist ja in diesem ZKM. Die haben so Lichthöfe und da ist halt irgendwie hoch, umringt immer von solchen mehretagigen Treppensystemen, wo du aber hochgucken kannst und dann kann man da irgendwie abchillen. Und es waren halt irgendwie genug Arbeitsplätze da und Sofalandschaften. Und es gab auch einen draußen wie einen dritten.
Also eine gute Mischung zwischen Hacking Space und Couch-Ecken und Quatschen können und Socialisen und Trinken.
Essen war da. Das ist vielleicht auch genau das, was ich meine. Es war eine extrem gut abgestimmte Veranstaltung. Von nichts war zu viel und von nichts war zu wenig da. Und das kann man irgendwie gar nicht besser beschreiben. Hat mir auf jeden Fall gefallen. Ich musste eben gerade noch mal grinsen, weil ich nämlich just während dieser Sendung eine E-Mail bekam vom Entropia e.V., der diese GPN ausrichtet. Und da musste ich wirklich kichern, weil, ich werfe das mal hier kurz in den Chat, die Lost-and-Found-Liste herumgeschickt wurde. Und zwar in besser Tradition, wie wir das irgendwann mal in Berlin von einem Kongress das erste Mal getan haben. Nämlich, indem man einfach Lost-and-Found alles fotografiert, was einfach gefunden wurde, das auf so eine Webseite packt. Und da steht es dann da. Und ich weiß noch, wir haben das... Es muss... Ich weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau. 21, C3, 20, C3... So die Zeit rum haben wir da irgendwie, das glaube ich, das erste Mal gemacht. Und ich weiß, dass diese Webseite danach sogar hier in das... Oh verdammt, in irgendein Museum. Ich glaube, deutsche Zeitgeschichte, irgendwie... Irgendwo unter den Linden, so ein Museum, was sich so mit Zeitgeschichten beschäftigt.
Ach so, das fand er toll.
Und da hat das irgendwie auch Einzug gefunden, weil die das einfach so absurd großartig fanden, was du quasi kulturell aus so einer Veranstaltung rauslesen konntest, nur anhand der Dinge, die...
Verloren wurden.
Die da einfach liegen gelassen wurden und hier musst du dich wieder so ein bisschen grinsen, weil es hat ja irgendwie von dem, was so, USB-Sticks hier, Netzteile natürlich, SD-Karten, Developer Boards, Decktelefone und dann halt so die typischen Hacker-Klamotten. Also auch wenn du nur so den Querschnitt dessen nimmst, was so verloren wird, merkst du halt einfach den Style sofort. Aber auch eine kleine Kindergiraffe ist dabei, paar Sonnenbrillen. Also an die ganze Familie ist gedacht und man ist auch cool, weil es gibt auch Sonnenbrillen.
Die von Starbucks.
Das hab ich auch gedacht.
Ja, auch schicke Haarspangen.
Das ist keine Haarspange, das ist ein Haarstab.
Oh, Entschuldigung. Einen schicker Haarstab.
Spange klemmt nur einer, da klemmt nix, richtig?
Richtig, da dreht man mit den Fingern so ein bisschen die Haare drum und schiebt die durch. Durch den Haarknoten. Sehr zu empfehlen bei langem Haar.
Wieder was gelernt.
Alternativ kann man auch den Bleistift nehmen. Aber da muss man aufpassen, dass hier vorne macht die Haare kaputt.
Und dann auch hier so dieses großartige Ding. Eine der ersten Anwendungen von 3D-Printern in der Nord-Szene.
Damit man die Mates voneinander unterscheiden kann, konnte man das auf die Mate stülpen und da stand der Name drauf oder der Nickname oder so.
Genau, so ein Mate-Clip, also ein Plastiklip, den man einfach oben an die Flaschen, im Flaschenhals ranklippt mit dem eigenen Namen drauf, sodass immer klar ist, wessen Mate das ist.
Ja, ich hab auch noch zwei zu Hause, aber nie benutzt.
Nee, die verliert man immer, das ist das Blöde, deswegen. Aber wenn sie hier im Lost&Fought auftauchen, ist das auch geil. Ja. Und ein Handtuch. Ist das ein Handtuch? Nee, das ist kein Handtuch. Das ist ein Bettlaken.
Das könnte auch ein Stück Stoff sein, einfach.
Ein komisches Muster.
Irgendjemand meinte Handtuch. Ah ja, hier ist noch ein Handtuch. Guck mal, ein Handtuch. Also da weiß irgendjemand nicht, wo sein Handtuch ist. Das ist natürlich schlecht, weil...
Wer hat ja noch ein zweites?
In zwei Tagen ist Towel Day, ne? Da müsste man dann schon mal nachrüsten. So, das war's von mir zur GPN. Will da noch jemand was hinzufügen? Was ist los?
Der Chat weist uns auf ein sehr wichtiges Ereignis hin.
26 Staffeln am Stück?
Dr. Who wird auf Twitch gestreamt ab dem 29. Am Stück! Was ist denn der 29.
Also ab dem 29. Mai.
Das heißt, jeder, der schlafen geht, hat schon verloren, ja?
Na, du kannst bei Twitch auf Pause drücken.
Die Frage ist ja auch, ob sie danach online gestellt werden.
Na, solange der Stream läuft, aber du kannst halt nie aufholen. Das ist das Problem, wenn er endet und sie den dann runternehmen.
Was heißt denn das konkret bei Twitch? Also, dass es nur live gestreamt wird und sonst nichts?
Nee, es kommt drauf an, glaube ich, wie deine Einstellungen sind als Twitch-Creator.
Genau, also es gibt Leute, die lassen ihre Livestreams dann auch als Aufzeichnung da noch online, aber es gibt auch Leute, die das nicht machen. Und dann, wenn der Stream zu Ende ist, dann kannst du halt nicht mehr. Oder dann nur noch so 24 Stunden oder sowas.
Und es kommt darauf an, ob du bei dem Kanal abonniert hast, also Geld dafür bezahlst, demjenigen, so ein bisschen das Patreon-Prinzip, dass du kannst dem Kanal eines Creators halt Geld geben monatlich, wie so ein Abo abschließen, oder es ist auch ein Abo. Und dann gibt es einige Leute, die dann einen bestimmten Teil nur für diese Abonnenten dann auch vorhalten, dass du sie nachher anschauen kannst.
Aber ja, das wird vielleicht in diesem Blogpost stehen, was sie denn gedenken, mit diesem Stream so zu veranstalten, weil niemand wird das ja schaffen. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Folgen 26 Staffeln hat eine Staffel.
Da ist keiner so lange wach. Nicht mal eine Staffel.
Also ich hab es geschafft, fünf Staffeln Lost in zwei Wochen zu gucken. Und das war schon Essen, Schlafen, Lost hauptsächlich. Aber 26 Staffeln, Dr. Who, klingt nach einer...
Das klingt genau nach dem, was ich...
Also ich kann auf jeden Fall, die ersten Folgen sind schon...
Das sind die ganz, ganz alten, oder?
Ja, das sind die ganz, ganz alten. Unearthly Child ist schon... Also guckt wenigstens so die ersten vier Folgen. Es ist schon echt krass und irgendwie cool. Allein wenn man halt so die Machart sieht. Und die haben halt auch ein anderes Format. Da haben halt irgendwie die Folgen, glaube ich, nur 10, 15 Minuten, weil die irgendwie so einen Zwischenslot hatten, den sie eigentlich füllen wollen. Aber im anderen Prinzip, eine Story geht dann über vier, fünf Folgen. Und ja, einfach so Kleidung von damals und was man gehört hat. Das ist viel mehr wie Theater.
Kritischheit.
Ne, ja, so ein bisschen. Also es gibt echt Staffeln, die so ein bisschen doll trashy sind. Aber so...
Ne, absolut nicht.
Also ich komm mit Dr. Who nicht. Eine Staffel hab ich gesehen. Ich kenn nur einen einzigen Doktor. Die fand ich geil.
Welche?
Das musst du jetzt natürlich raussuchen.
Wer war denn der Doktor?
Ich vermute Tenant, aber ich vermute auch.
Der hatte so eine Telefonzelle.
Ey, war der dann vielleicht auch blau und das war eine Telefonzelle, so eine Policebox? Das wäre nämlich total abgefahren.
Das ist schon so ein bisschen zum Ausloten, weil wenn sie blau war, war es ein Farbfernsehen.
Das stimmt. Die Frage ist aber welches.
Season 1 hat angeblich 42 Episoden.
Aber ich dachte, ein paar Seasons sind verloren gegangen und die gibt es gar nicht mehr.
Nicht komplette Seasons, aber einzelne Folgen. Da gibt es halt nur so Bilder, weil viel Fotografien von dem Set gemacht wurden, aber es gibt halt teilweise noch die Audiospuren. Das heißt, man kann dann trotzdem irgendwie so Bild hören.
So, wie heißt denn die Wikipedia-Seite, wo irgendwie alle Doktoren drauf sind?
Ich glaube, da kommst du über Google Images, da hast du dann ein so ein Bild.
Karek, geh doch mal ein Stück noch runter, bei dem, da, The Doctor. Da gibt es einen Main-Artikel. Rechts, rechts. Oder genau, da hast du die Bilder.
Der hier war das. Das ist Echo Stone, das ist die erste Serie von den neuen. Die ist am Anfang echt trashig.
Ja, die ist trashig, aber die hat auch einen Charme.
Ja, die hat ihren Charme. Im Prinzip ist es zwischenzeitlich ein bisschen eingeschlafen. Ich glaube, von dem Doctor davor gab es nur einen Film oder so. Der ist auch so, na ja. Aber mit Echo Stone hat es dann wieder angefangen. Und mit Tenet war dann so der... Ich muss sagen, Doctor Who hat teilweise doch schon einen Platz in meinem Herzen. Und ich muss sagen, Doctor Who hat die allerbeste Liebesgeschichte, die ich jemals kenne. Und ich bin nicht so richtig romantisch veranlagt, aber die ist echt cool.
Das kann ich ganz gut bezeugen.
Was ist denn hier die romantische Geschichte?
Professor Dr. River Song. Es gibt... Ich muss sagen, ich habe sogar... Spoiler alert. Wenn ich Leuten Doctor Who vorstellen soll möchte, habe ich im Prinzip die Wahl zwischen zwei Folgen. Die eine ist relativ creepy, nennt sich... Oh, wie heißt denn das mit dem Child? Are you my mommy?
Oh, das ist echt schwierig. Ist das nicht die, die auch der Chat gerade sagt, mit den Gasmasken?
Jaja, genau, die Gasmasken-Folge. Die sind beides Zweiteiler. Also eine ist wirklich eine creepy von Steven Moffat geschrieben. Ich glaube, das war Tenant oder Ecclestone. Eine von den beiden muss am Anfang gewesen sein. Ich guck gleich nochmal. Genau, und das andere ist halt Silence in the Library. Und in Silence in the Library wird Prof. Dr. Rivers Song eingeführt. Und ich möchte nicht spoilern, weil ihr die Folgen selber gucken sollt. Aber man merkt relativ am Anfang, dass sie halt den Doktor kennt und er sie nicht. Und das ist halt bei Zeitreisenden so ein schönes klassisches Problem. Und doch, Dr. Who macht vieles irgendwie richtig.
Ja, das ist wirklich so eine...
Kann man denn die Folgen gucken, ohne dass man den ganzen Rest gesehen hat? Sind die immer unabhängig voneinander?
Sie sind einen großen Teil. Also es gibt so einen allgemeinen Story-Arc, aber viele sind einzeln. Und ich würde sagen, wenn ihr so grob wisst, dass Dr. Who ein Zeitreisender ist, dann guckt euch ja...
Ich denke auch, weil ich hab auch mittendrin irgendwo mal eine Folge mit dem Tennant gesehen, wo ich Dr. Who noch nicht kannte. Und da hat das auch funktioniert. Und das Gute ist, ich hab sie erst auf Deutsch gesehen.
Tennant heißt der Schauspieler, ne?
Genau.
Der der auf Broadchurch gemacht hat?
Aber bei Broadchurch hat er natürlich den geilen schottischen Akzent, den hat er dann nicht.
War auch der Bösewicht in Jessica Jones.
Ein wirklich großartiger Schauspieler. Er hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Ich hab noch das Vergnügen, dass ich sie jetzt endlich alle auf...
The Empty Child.
Ja, auf Englisch schauen kann.
Und wenn man was auch eine sehr schöne ist, wo ich dann meistens die Van Gogh-Folge...
Oh, die Van Gogh-Folge ist auch super geil. Und die Folge mit den Ud. Die sind halt so ein bisschen traurig.
Und die Folge! Ich hab ja letztens jemanden getroffen, der noch nicht South Park gesehen hat. Nie.
Ja gut, aber ich fand South Park auch... Es war nie so meins.
Da waren aber schon coole Folgen dabei.
South Park ist doch wirklich...
also, bitte dich.
Entschuldigung, Dennis... Entschuldige, dass ich kurz unterbringe. Aber Dennis hat auch noch nicht IT-Crowd gesehen.
Jetzt geht das wieder los.
Aber bei South Park ist es ja auch so, dass du alle Folgen schon ewig lange kostenlos im Netz gucken kannst. Und mit einem Adblocker kriegst du nicht mal die Werbeeinblendung. Und die gibt es auf Deutsch, auf Englisch. Du kannst auch auf southpark.de gehen und Folge aussuchen, auf Englisch stellen und glücklich sein.
Southpark hat den Full Range bis maximale Epic. Also wirklich maximale Epic.
Vor allem da ist gesellschaftskritische Sachen drin.
Ja, also allein die Folge von Southpark zu Facebook mit dem Titel You have zero friends. Da ist alles drin, was du über das Thema Social Networking wissen musst. Das ist wirklich fantastisch.
Dann haben die eine Folge über WoW. Dann haben sie eine Folge über Walmart oder Amazon. Oder dass diese Großhändler die Kleinhände übernehmen. Da gibt es da auch was Geiles, oder? Dann gibt es das, wo ihm die Antennen aus dem Arsch wachsen. Was ist das nochmal? Mit den schwarzen Hubschraubern?
Klingt jetzt sehr einladend, aber...
Das war so ein Überwachungsding, glaube ich.
Und gleichzeitig haben sie auch zwei der besten, jemals in Filmen festgehaltenen Drogentrip-Visualisierungen dabei. Also, die auch wirklich sehr überzeugend kommen, wo man auf jeden Fall weiß, dass die Macher...
South Park ist kein Trash. South Park ist schon wirklich extrem großes Kino.
Das ist nix für Kinder eigentlich.
Aber ich finde, South Park kann ich immer nur in so einem Modus gucken.
Man kann wie Einsamern, man sollte nicht zu viel auf einmal dosieren.
Die Dosis macht das Gift, ja. Und ich hab auch natürlich die gleiche Person, hat auch nicht den Film Team America gesehen, den ich ja auch für absolut episch halte, weil der so ein Benchmark gesetzt hat für was kann man an political incorrectness und Dingen so aussprechen in so einem Breitbandmedium, was wirklich Millionen da noch sehen, was alle gedacht haben, aber keiner gewagt hat, so in den Mund zu den Plus natürlich Schmerzgrenze ausloten. Vor allem der Slow in dem Set-Team dann America! Ist ja das Ende dann, da vorne ist dann nur noch Fuck. Also der Film und South Park, die haben bei mir zum Beispiel auch einen sehr großen...
Team America, da gibt's auch.
Also Team America fände ich auch so ein Film, ich sag's nicht gerne.
Also, South Park ist toll, Team America ist auch wirklich pure Epic. IT-Crowd ist trotz unberechtigter Zweifel...
Ich guck's ja auch nicht.
Fantastisch. Ich hab da in den letzten zwei Wochen nochmal viel drüber nachgedacht und alle eure Einwände sind Bogos. Sogar das mit dem Lachen, was ich gar nicht wusste.
Nee, das wusste ich auch nicht.
Das ist ja nicht eingespielt, sondern das ist tatsächlich live.
Aber es gibt auch IT-Crowd und dann gibt's aber noch so eine andere, oder?
Genau. Nee, aber das kann ich nicht vergleichen.
Das will ich auch gar nicht, aber das geht beide nicht.
Nein, das spielt mich bei mir genauso.
Dennis, beim nächsten Mal, wenn wir uns zum WoW-Zocken treffen, wird IT-Crowd nehmen.
Aber richtig. IT-Crowd muss man komplett drauf haben.
Nein, 2 gegen 1 ist nicht...
Warte, Deal, Deal, wir machen Deal. Wir gucken eine IT-Crowd und wir gucken eine South Park-Folge.
Nein, wir wollen doch zocken.
Und wir gucken eine Doktor. Du musst den doch nicht haben, die müssen den haben.
Du kannst den Kopfhörer aufsetzen und zocken.
Danach können wir euch die romantische Liebesgeschichte über Dr. Ruhe anschauen.
Na, Romantik kannst du ja auch nicht.
Naja, aber das kam ja noch durch.
Das hat einen Platz in meinem Herzen. Ich habe ein Herz für River Song.
Aber mit mir würdest du dich schon gucken, oder? Nur, du wolltest es noch klarstellen.
Ja, wir kriegen das schon hin. Aber ich glaube, wir können das ja testen, weil ich will ja nicht sagen, dass ich was kacke finde, ohne zu wissen, dass ich es kacke finde. Dann gucke ich die nochmal, dann kann ich danach noch viel besser sagen, ich finde es scheiße.
Aber ich gucke hier nicht nochmal Blade Runner für dich.
Wieso für mich?
Bitte nicht alle Funden gleichzeitig.
Welchen Blade Runner?
Den ersten.
Der ist super.
Oh, sieh'rote Pille, wenn man sie braucht.
Also ich kann das schon verstehen, dass Leute Blade Runner nicht mögen, weil es wirklich 80er-Trash ist. Wenn man das jetzt nachträglich guckt, doch von der Machart ist das schon noch ganz schön teilweise. So sind wir heute halt eben nicht mehr. Versetz dich mal in einen Reihen, der heute Avatar guckt und Interstellar und weiß nicht alles. Der kann kein Blade Runner gucken. Da denken die, was ist denn das?
Das Pacing ist halt grundlegend anders. Ich seh Blade Runner eher als Art von Kunst. Und es ist halt wie bei Kunst, Kunst ist subjektiv. Manche mögen's. Ich find...
Fahrt euch wieder runter. Ich werd mir demnächst die 70mm-Kopie von 2001 im Kino anschauen. Ja, aber wenn du das erfahren hast, redest du nicht mehr darüber, wie langsam ein Film war. Also, Blade Runner ist im Vergleich zu 2001 wie eine South Park-Episode.
Weißt du, sie haben ja von Eldian noch mal eine neue Edition rausgebracht. Also so eine Art Directors Cut oder wie auch immer. Ist wahrscheinlich auch schon zehn Jahre her. Aber jetzt, was sie gemacht haben, sie haben Sachen nicht... Weil meistens Directors Cut ja länger als früher, weil sie noch Szenen haben, die sind noch mit reingelatscht. Und das haben sie auch gemacht. So ein paar Szenen, die verdeutlichen noch mal so Sachen. Aber sehr wenige. Aber insgesamt haben sie den Film kürzer gemacht, weil sie meinen, die Leute von heute, die würden das nicht mehr aushalten, wenn der Film so langsam vorwärts geht und haben ihn sozusagen ein bisschen beschleunigt dadurch, aber auch kürzer gemacht. Also das heißt, es gibt schon Unterschiede zwischen den Sehgewohnheiten von vor, keine Ahnung, 30 Jahren. Blade Runner ist ja jetzt auch 34 Jahre alt, oder was? 84? 2008? Und ich kann das schon verstehen. Aber ich finde trotzdem, vielleicht sollte man nicht so viel optisch hingucken, sondern mehr auf die Dialoge und so achten. Und ich, ja, ich bin da irgendwie Fan von. Aber ich kann das nachvollziehen, wenn Hucke sagt, 80er Trash und das geht gar nicht.
Nee, ich hab gar nicht überhaupt, ich hab überhaupt nicht gesagt.
Hast du mal gesagt...
Nee, ich hab nicht gesagt, 80er Trash.
Das haben wir hier, nicht schriftlich, aber als Podcast.
Bring es die Stelle, die Soundsample bitte, Internet, wo ich sage, dass es Trash ist. Ich hab nicht gesagt, dass es Trash ist.
Ich dachte, der Tim hat gerade Transkripte von Podcasts.
Ich hab das Wort Trash, glaube ich, nicht in den Mund genommen.
Dann hast du es aber so ähnlich gesagt und zumindest so gemeint. So bäh.
Ich, äh, ja, wie gesagt, ich hab ja, also in meiner Erinnerung hab ich auch genauso argumentiert, dass es halt andere Sehgewohnheiten sind. Und ich, mit dieser 80er Jahre, da ist ja genau dieser Umbruch, wo so das Action, Kino und so weiter so richtig losgegangen ist. Und ja, der Blade Runner ist halt noch so vor dem Umbruch.
Ich kann das nachvollziehen, weil ich hab letztens...
Ich kann mir aber auch Filme aus den 50er Jahren anschauen, die hervorragend sind, weil die waren damals hervorragend.
Alle drei, ja. Alle drei Filme, die aus den 50ern sind. Zähl mal auf.
Es gibt richtig viele gute Filme. Ja, jetzt zähl mal auf. Also auswendig alle Filme, die du gut findest.
Mir fallen zwei auf jeden Fall ein.
Ich kann durch Letterboxd gehen und dir das irgendwie aufzählen.
Also ein Film, der richtig großartig ist, wenn man sich halt mit Filmen auskennt, wenn man es schafft, sich in die Lage hineinzuversetzen, wie der Film hätte eigentlich aussehen müssen für die Zeit, ist Citizen Kane. Wenn du den guckst und dann guckst du auf das Jahr, wo der produziert wurde, und du guckst dir andere Filme an, die dem gleichen Jahr rauskamen, oder auch noch zehn Jahre später, dann denkst du dir, wow, was hat der da abgeliefert? Das ist so ein bisschen wie 2001. Der war einfach mal 20 Jahre von einer Schnitttechnik und von Kamerabewegung voraus. Die Story ist nicht lame, das Ende ist lame.
Aber das Gegenbeispiel wäre z.B. so was wie 12 Angry Men, wo Technik halt total low budget ist, aber alle in einem Raum sitzen, aber die Story halt total großartig ist.
Ja, aber da könnte man auch klar sagen, der Film an sich ist ja auch nicht cool, sondern die Story, weil es hätte auch, oder war wahrscheinlich sogar ein Theaterstück, oder?
Kann sein, ne. Oder, ich weiß nicht, Soy Kuba ist ja wahrscheinlich aus den 60ern. Genau, aber der ist ja visuell auch ultra spektakulär. Von wann ist der 64?
Für die Zeit, ja. Nee, aber wo mir das eingefallen ist mit Blade Runner, dass ich das verstehen kann, wenn Leute damit irgendwie nicht so warm werden, wenn sie das Jahre später gucken. Ich hab letztens mir dann doch endlich mal Rocky Horror Picture Show angeguckt. Ja, nee, das ist ein 70er-Trash.
Sagst du nicht immer Trash? Das ist ein hervorragender Film.
Aber Trash ist noch ein positiv besetztes Wort heutzutage.
Ja, aber gut, vielleicht nicht unbedingt.
Also schlechte Filme würde man ja Schrott nennen. Guter, guter Schrott ist ja Trash. Nein, falsch, falsch. Zurückspulen. Aber ich kam da auch nicht so mit warm. Und die Story war auch so lala. Also, ja.
Für mich hat halt Blade Runner, glaube ich, immer so ein kleiner Platz.
In deinem Herzen. Es hängt da langsam.
Ja, es gibt nicht viel da, aber Doctor Who und Blade... Shadowrun, Shadowrun, definitiv.
Shadowrun kenne ich nicht, aber ich finde schon die Zitate oder was man so quoten kann von Blade Runner ist schon...
Also ich fand die letzte Szene bei Blade Runner eigentlich...
Welcher Schnitt, welcher Cut? Ja, das ist wichtig. Gerade das Ende. Es gibt mehrere Enden von Blade Runner. Im Original, also wie es in den Kino kam, da war das Ende geklaut von The Shining, wenn du mal vergleichst. Vom Anfang von The Shining, wie die zu diesem Hotel mit dem Auto fahren. Das haben sie dann ans Ende von Blade Runner rangeklebt, wie sie halt mit dem Auto oder mit dem Fahrzeug da in den Wäldern irgendwie langfahren. Das war das Ende von Blade Runner, wenn du das meinst.
Also ich meine den Monolog von dem letzten Sterbenden. Dieser Sterbende, der...
All these moments are lost in time, like tears in rain, bubende, taubendig weg.
Das war für mich so, wo ich dachte, das ist ein großartiger Dialog, aber das war so gefühlt der einzige, den ich da drin gefunden habe. Aber was ich wieder...
Also da kann ich ja aus dem Stegreifen und ich war wirklich nie... Also Gedichte lernen musste ich zum Glück nie. Zum Glück. Aber da könnte ich jetzt loslegen. Da können wir nochmal...
Ich muss meine Herzpillen nehmen.
Nimm mal deine Pillen. Aber ich, was ich zum Beispiel finde, wo Tala total recht hat, ich finde den Film optisch eine Augenweide. Also ich finde den halt, der sieht sehr, sehr kunstvoll aus. Und das fand ich dann eher, wo ich gemerkt habe, krass so eine, so optisch, so sehr schöne Filme.
Und vor allem die Musik dazu.
Der war damals genre-definierend.
Also das war die Optik. Der ist gefloppt im Kinotim.
Trotzdem war er genre-definierend.
Naja, aber er ist gefloppt. Wie kann man was definieren, wenn es floppt? Hat ja keiner gesehen.
Man kann immerhin den unteren Maßstab setzen.
Ein paar Jahre später kam das Ding ja.
Die haben erst später gemerkt, dass das so geil ist.
Ja, aber trotzdem haben dann alle irgendwie diese Optik auch aufgegriffen.
Es dauert ja auch eine Weile, bis man mit so was warm wird.
Es ist halt nicht für jeden, aber es gibt definitiv Gönner und Genießer.
Und vor allem die Leute hatten ja auch Schwierigkeiten, das zu verstehen mit diesen Androiden und wussten ja nicht, war Deckard jetzt selber einer oder nicht. Das war ja früher eben nicht so klar. Die Leute haben das ja alle nicht so kapiert.
Was ja auch daran lag, dass sie halt erst die falschen Versionen von diesem Film ins Kino gelassen haben.
Weil sie dachten, die Leute sind überfordert, aber waren sie ja wahrscheinlich auch.
Genau, man hätte das Ding einfach mal von Anfang an. Also ich, ja, die Leute überfordert. Ach, die meisten Leute sind doch immer überfordert. Also ich weiß doch, dass Blade Runner war so einer der Filme damals, wo ich wirklich so... Es gibt da nicht so richtig viele, an die ich mich erinnern kann, wo ich so wirklich so latent geschockt aus dem Kino rauskam. Wo ich mir dachte so, was in aller Welt? Weil also, wo danach irgendwie alles anders war. Das ging mir bei Star Wars so, da kam es auf Star Wars raus.
Aber da war ich auch noch sehr klein, da hättest du mich auch mit ganz anderen Sachen geschockt.
War aber so. Und ging auch, glaube ich, an anderen, die nicht zehn Jahre alt waren.
Ja, das weiß ich nicht.
Ja, ich hab auch Bummy geguckt, danach war nicht alles anders.
War die nicht tot denn und das war voll schlimm?
Also ich hab das schon gemacht.
Die Welt war... So, und Pipe Fiction ging es mir so? Pipe Fiction war auch so ein totaler Knockout-Moment.
Matrix, der erste Teil.
Matrix, genau.
Brasil. Das war schon ein Schocker.
Brasil hat mich überhaupt nicht losgelassen, aber that's just me.
Mich hat ja so ein bisschen Lost Highway aus dem Sessel gerissen.
Also gibt's schon so Filme, denen man sofort ansieht, dass sie irgendwie was langes sind. Und Huckel, du wolltest ja noch ein paar 50er-Jahre-Beispiele haben. Ich hab jetzt nur ein paar, aber...
Das reicht ja, also...
Hier, wie ist der Name auf Deutsch? Fenster zum Hof, Rear Window, also Hitchcock generell.
Also nicht...
Ja, Vertigo ist auch 50er.
Wobei ich nicht alle Hitchcock-Filme geil finde, aber der Fenster zum Hof ist auf jeden Fall einer der cooleren. Definitiv.
Und gut, ich könnte jetzt weiter so mit Hitchcock machen, der hat halt die 50er und die 60er Jahre...
Was halt geil ist, ist noch der neuere aus den 70ern, so ein Hitchcock, ich glaube sein letzter war das, hieß der Familiengrab oder so. Ich weiß nicht, ob der English Family Grave heißt, wahrscheinlich nicht. Aber der mit dem Diamanten oder so.
Da war was, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich den gesehen habe.
Mit Bruce Dern, dem Papa von Laura Dern. Family Plot, ja, genau.
Letzter Film, genau.
Ja, der ist auch ziemlich cool eigentlich.
Den kenn ich gar nicht.
Ja, den kann ich ja empfehlen. Der ist nicht so schlecht.
Watchlist. Nicht, dass ich da oft nachschaue, aber man weiß ja nie.
Und Psycho kann man eigentlich auch immer wieder gucken.
Ja, das wär noch der andere, genau.
Und die Vögel. Immer wieder super.
Echt, den find ich zum Beispiel mega lame.
Nee, ich find, der hat sowas John Carpenter-mäßiges.
Also das fand ich die Mv-Mörder cooler.
Der ist sowieso mein Favorite, weil ich mir immer wieder nicht merken kann, wie sie die Verdrehungen mit dem Schlüssel machen. Jedes Mal guck ich mir, boah, ist das genial. Dann will ich's einem erzählen und sag, wie war das? Aber den find ich richtig cool.
Also ich glaube, von Hitchcock waren Fenster zum Hufen, von Mörder die Favorites. Aber genau, ich hab ja dann noch hier 12 Angry Men. Das ist auch noch ein Film, den ich aus den 50ern noch geil finde. Also nach 1950, wie war das? Wenn man 1958s hat, sind's eigentlich die 60er schon. Du bist ja sozusagen auch immer, ich bin jetzt 35, aber in meinem 36. Lebensjahr quasi. Und wenn man 1956 bist, ist es schon in den 60ern. Oder wie war das? La Dolce Vita ist natürlich genau an der Grenze leider.
Also man sagt auch, die 80er Jahre sind doch dann von 80 bis 89. Ist ein bisschen mit Klopfen, aber ist irgendwie so.
Irgendwie so eine Verwirrung gab's da.
Mit dem Jahrhundert da ist das so mit dem von da vorne.
Aber ja, so viel anderes, also da gibt's zwar Filme, die gut bewertet sind, aber jetzt keine, die mich dann noch irgendwie so vom Hocker gehauen haben.
Ja, aber doch, es gibt so viele Filme, die toll sind. Weil die können einem gar nicht alle einfallen.
Ich gucke ja hier gerade auf IMDB Advanced Search, alle Filme zwischen 1950 und 1960, die eine Score über 7,5 haben. Da sind schon die ganzen Klassiker dabei. Hier Streetcar Named Desire und so.
Das ist einer der besten Performances, die ich gesehen habe, glaube ich. Ich glaube, hier ist die Szene, wo Marlon Brando sich aufregt. Und du denkst gleich, bringt er sie um. Aber nicht im Film, sondern irgendwie in echt. Das ist kein Schauspieler mehr. Ich weiß nicht, es kam so krass rüber, habe ich noch nie gesehen im Film, dass einer so in die Rolle rein ist, wie in diesem Film. Kasinski, wie er sich nennt oder heißt im Film.
Hat Tim denn jetzt endlich schon von Jim Jarmusch Only Lovers Left Alive gesehen?
Hab ich immer noch nicht gesehen.
Auch nicht. Also das ist wirklich ein Film, der ist mir im Kopf geblieben, weil ich den großartig fand. Dieses gesamte Konstrukt, was er da gebaut hat. Also ich weiß nicht, das...
Ich hab ihn nicht gesehen.
Aber das hatten wir schon in der letzten Sendung, oder? Gleich sind wir wieder bei Ice Cream.
Ich hab ihn sogar auf meiner Watchlist, aber das war's dann auch schon. Ja, ich komm wenig zum Film gucken, um ehrlich zu sein. Also ich hab, wenn ich hier mal dazu komme, mal das zu taggen. Ich durfte mir jetzt sozusagen mal diese ganze Harry Potter-Geschichte dann auch endlich mal anschauen.
Ah ja, geil. Die haben ja auch...
Viel ja nicht so in meiner Zeit irgendwie, deswegen...
Die ersten, wo die noch so ganz klein waren, die fand ich ja so ein bisschen nervig, aber dann später waren das schon echt korrekte Filme.
Es wurde mir aber auch gesagt, dass es sich lohnt, erst später die Bücher zu lesen, weil ich halt den Fehler gemacht habe, dieses erste Buch zu lesen und dachte mir nach wenigen Seiten so, oh nee, diesen Kinderkack muss ich mir jetzt hier nicht anheben. Harry Potter.
Ja, ich war halt genau in dem Alter.
Ja, da war ich halt schon raus. Das war das Doof.
Oh, da gibt es auch gerade noch einen super Tipp.
Ich bin mit Pokemon aufgewachsen, so jung bin ich.
Andromeda's Drain, einer meiner Favorites. Ich weiß nicht warum, wahrscheinlich war ich auch noch zu klein, weil es eigentlich auch keine Elchipo Trash, oder? Aber irgendwie kommt der so geil spannend drüber am Anfang.
Dieser Trash, der ist doch total spannend, der Film.
Ach, wenn Leute dich heute den angucken, die lachen nicht aus. Ich hab den selber auch noch mal gesehen.
Aber Spannung hat doch nicht... Das ist auch das, was mich in dieser ganzen, als wir hier über diese ganze YouTube-Welt gesprochen haben, was bitte ist die Qualität dieser Hektik? Also dieses schnelle Schnitte und so weiter.
Wir sind hier in der fucking Großstadt, die Leute haben keine Aufmerksamkeit mehr.
Das kommt doch völlig darauf an, was man guckt bei YouTube. Ist da nicht jeder so ein Drottel, der alles abgehackt zusammenschneidet?
Naja, aber es ist schon so Jumpcut Festival.
Jumpcut Festival. Sendungstitel tralala.
Ja, aber es ist wirklich so.
Alles muss schnell schnell sein, keine Pausen.
Alles muss schnell geschnitten sein. Auch die Kinderfilme heutzutage sind alles schnell geschnitten. Und es heißt halt immer so, und ich sehe das ja auch, dass die sich daran gewöhnen. Und wenn du dann alte Sachen zeigst, dann kommt halt auch wieder langsam und so weiter. Nur das heißt ja nicht, dass nicht in dieser Langsamkeit sich genauso gut eine Geschichte auch gut entwickeln kann und teilweise meiner Meinung nach auch besser entwickeln kann. Also Andromeda-Strain zum Beispiel. Wenn ich mich an den, wie heißt er nochmal? Andromeda, tödlicher Staub aus dem All.
Irgendwie sowas.
Genau. Und ich weiß noch, den hab ich irgendwie in na so ein paar Jahre nachdem er rauskam, irgendwie in Deutschland im Fernsehen gesehen.
Und er hat mich irgendwie völlig in den Bann gezogen.
Weil die Story sich einfach so geil entwickelt hat.
Der Anfang ist mega spannend.
Ja, ist irre. Also es ist ja so, was weiß ich, es gibt so ein Ereignis und in irgendeiner Stadt sind irgendwie alle tot.
Außer?
Außer zwei.
Ein Alkoholiker und ein Baby.
Genau.
Dass die wissen nicht warum und müssen damit anzugreifen und testen und so.
Genau. Und deswegen funktioniert dieser Film auch so gut. Das ist ja immer das, was ich so Billigproduktion immer vorwerfen. Ja, ich glaube, da gab es auch so einen Andromeda, nicht sogar ein Remake. Das ist bestimmt furchtbar. Auf jeden Fall. Gehst ja halt schnell so auf diese eigentliche Geschichte und dann müssen da maximal viele Aliens rumschreien und so weiter, damit das irgendwie spannend ist. Der Film ist halt komplett anders. Und da das jetzt auch eine Empfehlung ist, für Leute, die den nicht kennen, den kennen wahrscheinlich viele nicht, sich den Film mal zu geben und zwar wirklich auch mit Ruhe zu geben und nicht zu erwarten so, oh jetzt hier geil, Science Fiction Rocker. Das Ding ist Science Fiction, das Ding ist spannend, aber es entwickelt diese Spannung aus so einer Ruhe heraus und was ich halt auch geil finde, eben auch so aus so einer Charakterentwicklung heraus. Also sich halt auch Zeit nehmen, die beteiligten Leute dort zu bringen. Und ja, ich will überhaupt nichts spoilern. Ist einfach gut gemacht, wie die Story sich so entwickelt und was dann sozusagen die Auflösung des Rätsels ist.
Tolles Ding. Ich hab dann aus der gleichen Zeit, in der gleichen Macht, noch Empfehlungen. Und zwar Phase 4. Das ist so ein Film, wo so Forscher so Ameisen beobachten sollen. Und die Ameisen nehmen so ein bisschen Überhand. Der ist ziemlich geil. Dann noch, glaube ich, hieß der...
Phase 4?
Geht auf jeden Fall um Ameisen. Also wenn es um Ameisen geht, dann ist es der Richtige. Und dann gibt es noch ein... Casio-Pyre-Project? Nee. Dieses russische Ding? Nee, dann haben die mich jetzt wegen Casio-Pyre durcheinander gemacht. Das weiß ich jetzt nicht. Muss ich gleich googeln. Und dann gibt es noch Westworld, was ja mein Ultraklassiker ist. Das ist einer meiner Lieblingsfilme. Deswegen gibt es jetzt auch die Serie dazu. Aber eigentlich will man den Film mit Jules Brenner als den Bad-Dings da gucken, weil das ist einfach auch eine Top-Performance. Also das, was der da hingelegt hat, da wusste ich, da können die so viel Westworld nachdrehen, jetzt wie sie wollen, haben die keine Chance gegen. Haben sie auch gar nicht probiert, da ist ja was Gutes rausgekommen. Aber man sollte noch mal das Original gucken. Was auch nicht schlimm ist, weil er mit der Serie jetzt nichts zu tun hat oder nichts verrät oder sonst wie. Aber das ist einfach das Ding. Und der wird uns in der Zukunft, kann man so sagen, noch mal einholen, diese Story. Weil das wird ja so irgendwann mal kommen. Kann man mal von ausgehen.
Ist ja...
Ist nicht mehr weiter entfernt. Und gibt es noch einen zweiten Teil von dem Westworld. Da nehmen sie das noch ein bisschen weiter. Futureworld heißt der, den will man auch gucken. Ist ein bisschen billiger gemacht, aber knüpft gut an eigentlich. So und wie ist der andere, den ich meine? Den muss ich unbedingt noch rausfinden.
Roboter im Sternbild Cassiopeia?
Nee, nee, nee.
Der Wurf warf gerade der Clemens.
Scheiße, wie ist der Typ? Wie ist der Haupt... No Country for Old Men, wie ist da der Hauptdarsteller?
Warte, ich bin gerade bei dem, die B. Ja, dem, bei...
Nee, der andere, der gute.
So der Gute, ja warte.
Weil sein Papa spielt nämlich in dem anderen... Brolin, der, den mein ich, genau. Capricorn One, genau, den. Und hier hab ich auch gerade gesehen, unsere Leute im Chat sind ja richtig gut. Hier im Flucht ins 13. Jahrhundert oder im Originaltitel Logan's Run, der ist auch richtig super.
Das ist der einzige Film von dem, den du jetzt die ganze Zeit Wettestich gesehen hab.
Der ist wirklich super. Ich hab ja eine Weile einen Clubkino gemacht und all diesen ganzen Trash, den ich gerade erwähnt hab und auch die hab ich da alles mal durchgezeigt. Ich hatte immer nicht so viele Zuschauer, aber es kam immer gut.
Ich hab einige auch davon gesehen.
Ja, es war immer ein Spaß. Einmal noch mal den ganzen alten, alten Scheißen mal durchgucken. Das war mir eine große Freude. Auch VHS-Cassetten noch teilweise, ne? Ja, sollten wir ja eh öfter machen, so ein bisschen.
Ist eigentlich ganz gut, aber dann müssen wir uns mal mehr zu Dingen verpflichten.
Wie meinst du?
Ja, weißt du nicht, dass man sich mal auf einen Film einigt und dann schauen den auch mal alle.
Es ist natürlich schwierig, in einer dynamischen Konstellation. Ja, es ist immer schwierig, das zeitmäßig so hinzubekommen, dass das Ding auch gerade, also Blade Runner wäre jetzt ja sowas gewesen, oder Star Wars, wo man halt mal, wo denn auch, also wie sagt man, gerade aktuelles Thema, dass wir dann da so mitreden können, wenn man das ein halbes Jahr später, man interessiert das ja dann wieder auch nicht mehr so richtig. Deswegen finde ich eigentlich, über alte Filme noch mal zu reden, auch gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja, ich habe auch nicht von neuen Filmen geredet, sondern von durchaus eben von sowas, was weiß ich hier, scrollen einer nach dem anderen.
Ja, hier kommen die richtigen Dinger. Soylent Green ist natürlich auch immer vorne mit dabei.
Und das sind alles so Filme, die in der Ruhe die Kraft entwickeln.
Ja, mein absoluter Lieblingsfilm, also All-Time-Favorite, im Sinne von, finde ich, den besten Film überhaupt in jeder Kategorie. Das ist ja der Pate. Und das ist ja auch ein sehr ruhigerer Zeitgenosse an Filmen. Also das ist ja auch nicht so Action-Cut.
Aber es gab doch in dem zweiten Teil schon, also mir ist das aufgefallen, weil ich habe die vor kurzem, den ersten, den zweiten, aber ich glaube, den dritten jetzt noch nicht gesehen.
Ja, der dritte, den mussten wir noch nicht unbedingt sehen.
Aber ich fand halt, an einigen Stellen war es mir zu viel offensichtliches Geballer einfach. Also wo es dann halt so, okay, jetzt stirbt der nächste Jahr, war klar, dass du jetzt auch noch stirbst. Also weißt du, es ist dann halt irgendwann so dieses...
Ja, aber es ist halt die Eskalation von dem ersten. Aber da ist ja das Großartige, dass halt der junge Robert De Niro und der junge Al Pacino beide in hochklassiger Form unterwegs sind. Und gerade...
Die sie dann auch jahrelang dann nicht mehr waren, bis sie Hit zusammen gedreht haben.
Genau, und Robert De Niro gerade in jungen Jahren, ist ja dann auch, also diese Besetzung einfach von diesem Film ist schon...
Und Marlon Brando natürlich wieder.
Weltklasse. Was ja auch teilweise wohl Zufälle waren, glückliche. Dass das so gekommen ist, weil Al Pacino glaube ich...
Ich schmeiße jetzt einen Klassiker nach dem anderen hier und chatte.
Ja, blow up, der Ende ist auf jeden Fall auf Ruh.
Ihr macht es mir nur wieder schwer, die Show noch zusammen zu filmen. Die Sendung kommt heute Nacht nicht mehr raus. Versprechen. Ja, da kann man sich jetzt ewig versteifen, irgendwie Filmtipps geben. Ich finde es besser, man stellt sich jetzt, man reduziert das mal auf ein paar Filme.
Nein, alle! Wir gehen mit dem IMDB Top 250 Donut Show.
Ja, hab ich gesehen, der war gut, der war gut. Ja, der war nicht so geil, aber den kann man auch gucken und so. Hilft halt keinem.
Ja, vor allem, wie manche schon bemerkt haben, wir erwähnen ja auch immer die gleichen Filme.
Das sind halt die besten. Ihr sagt, einer Goodfellas ist besser als der Party.
Habt ihr überhaupt gar keine Ahnung. Das ist so, Gott, am Ende machen wir noch einen Podcast über Fernsehserien.
Haben wir schon gemacht.
So tief. Und dich nicht sinken.
Drei Stück haben wir schon gemacht.
Dann wären wir mit Dr. Who schon ganz offen und auf einem ganz guten Weg.
Ja, also genau, kehren wir mal zurück und machen die Klammer zu. Dr. Who kann man sich mal geben. Ich kenn's nicht richtig gut. Die einen Staffel, die ich gesehen habe, fand ich dann spannend genug, dass ich sie mir auch zu Ende angeschaut hab. Und wer die nächste Staffel mit demselben Doktor weitergelaufen hätte, der hätte es mir vielleicht noch weiterhin angeschaut, hab ich aber nicht. Jetzt steht erst mal 2001 an. Den kenn ich zwar mehr oder weniger in- und auswendig, aber ich bin trotzdem gespannt, wie sehr der im Original zu Beeindrucken vermag. Weil den hab ich noch nie gesehen, auf 70 Millimeter.
Also auch noch nicht den Blu-ray-Scan sozusagen, wo sie es nochmal sozusagen gescannt und ein bisschen aufgepeppt haben?
Ja, Digital-Kram, aber der wird richtig auf 70 Millimeter gezeigt.
Naja, aber du hast sozusagen schon mal...
Original-Kopie unbearbeitet. Das Original-Tea.
Okay, aber du hast schon mal einen Eindruck gewonnen, was sozusagen das Material hergibt mit der anderen Version.
Ja, kann ich jetzt grad nicht genau sagen, in welcher Qualität ich den gesehen habe, aber ich glaub, das ist auch irgendwo...
Ich glaub, es ist auch ein Film, mit dem man im Kino besser guckt.
Ich hab den halt mal auf so einer Uni, als wir da so fette neue HD-Fernseher anschaffen sollten, und wie auch immer dann ruhig gefragt, welche Geräte und so, und dann hab ich da so ein paar getestet und hatte dann irgendwie geguckt in der Videothek, was gibt's denn hier so in... Und dann hab ich mir auch den 2001 Blu-ray mal mitgenommen und war echt geschockt, wie gut der aussieht. Vor allen Dingen, weil meistens ja bei so zum Beispiel Star Trek oder Star Wars, wenn man da irgendwie genauer hinguckt, dann siehst du halt, wie billig eigentlich die Attrappen und Konsolen und so alle sind. Und bei 2001 sieht das auch in der Blu-ray-Version alles noch ziemlich glaubwürdig und echt aus.
Erzähl noch mal kurz zu dem 2001, wo der läuft. Das ist ja jetzt so ein Special, oder? Das heißt, da ist jetzt weltweit auch ein 70mm am Start. Hat nicht der John Gruber auch mal, der ist ja auch so ein Kubrick-Fan, der hat das doch auch schon mal erwähnt irgendwie.
Das kann sein, ja.
Das heißt, das war dann die Vorpremiere von dem 70mm und jetzt ist das sozusagen ausgerollt. Verstehe. Also man kann ja ganz normal gucken, das ist auch nicht so ein einzelner Termin, sondern so ein bisschen länger und öfter und so weiter.
Es gibt nicht viele Termine. Okay. Es gibt so 6, 7, 8.
Und Superlast? Oder war ich auch schon...
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Da war ich noch klein und scheiße. Jetzt bin ich nur noch scheiße.
So, ich mach mal hier... So, hier mal wieder zurückzukommen. Haben wir noch ein Thema? Wir könnten uns noch über die.
G-O-N-A-L.
Das ist das Thema, wenn man einschlafen will.
Da gibt es schon interessante Aspekte zu. Bestimmt. Finde ich jetzt nicht mehr so die Kraft, da jetzt noch mit vollem Schwung.
Ich fand das jetzt nur so kulturell ganz interessant. Ich fühle mich jetzt weder beruflich noch in der Lage, hier ein rechtliches Roundup zu geben, mit was denn da jetzt nun wirklich alles darunterfällt und was das für Konsequenzen hat.
Hat das für dich eigentlich Konsequenzen? Du hast ja so ein paar Webseiten am Start. Aber du hast keine User-Daten, die du sammelst. Deswegen fällt das da nicht runter.
Das ist egal. Es muss ja quasi jeder, der irgendwie geschäftsmäßig ist, zumindest mal deklarieren, was Sache ist.
Aber nur geschäftsmäßig. Aber es ist geschäftsmäßig.
Das, was ich mache, ist auf jeden Fall geschäftsmäßig.
Die Webseite auch?
Na ja, in beiden Podcasts damit verdiene ich mein Geld.
Aber es sind ja Spenden.
Das ist vollkommen irrelevant. Also erstens ist das ja nicht alles, was ich mache. Und zweitens ist das vollkommen unerheblich, wie du das jetzt nennst. Es ist halt sozusagen Income, selbstständige Arbeit und von daher ist es selbstverständlich, dass geschäftsmäßig...
Aber dann würde ja heißen, dass wenn ich ein Hobbyprojekt mache und wir Leute spenden, dann bin ich ja auch schon geschäftsmäßig, oder wie? Also wo ist der da Übergang dabei?
Ich wollte jetzt keine rechtliche Diskussion führen, weil das ist schwierig. Ich kann das alles nicht genau definieren. Geschäftsmäßig heißt zum Beispiel nicht unbedingt, dass du damit Business machst, sondern auch was die Kita irgendwie macht, ist sozusagen das Geschäft der Kita etc. Aber nagel mich nicht fest, das ist, wie es hier so schön heißt, im Zweifel ist es immer geschäftsmäßig. Und man muss halt jetzt einfach mal eine Ansage machen, wie es denn nun aussieht, was man denn tut, auch wenn man nichts tut, aber man muss zumindest mal einen Ansprechpartner benennen. Und für größere Unternehmen, die halt auch wirklich viele Daten durch die Gegend schaufeln, ist das jetzt halt auch ein echtes strammes Ding. Und im Prinzip ist es ja auch so, dass ein Großteil dieser Gesetze, zumindest in Deutschland, insofern ja schon galt, dass sich bloß halt niemand drum gekümmert hat. Und jetzt kommen halt die Bußen dazu und jetzt bewegen sich alle! Und das finde ich irgendwie cool.
Ich finde es auch ganz schön geil, wer da nicht wirklich jetzt alles aus den Löchern kommt und so, oh, okay, okay, jetzt müssen wir wohl was machen.
Also, vieles mag am Ziel vorbei sein, manches mag Schwierigkeiten mit Nachsicht ziehen, da wird es auch kritische Fälle geben, da wird sicherlich auch irgendein Abwahn Wahnsinn gestartet werden, ob der dann erfolgreich ist, steht natürlich nochmal auf dem anderen Blatt. All diese ganzen Sachen, alles richtig. Nur dieses, dass ich da mal was tun muss, nachdem das sozusagen so lange immer ignoriert wurde, das ist ja auch klar und offensichtlich ging es ja nicht anders, als eben jetzt die ganz große Keule rauszuholen.
Das war so ein ganz geilen Tweet, der ist immer in der Timeline vorbei, den ich gerade in die Shownotes noch getan hab, wo so eine Dame vom Regen umspült wird und drüber steht me letting all the GDPR emails wash over me and not responding to any of them. So geht es mir auch gerade, diese ganzen Newsletter, die einen jetzt so bitte Winsel, Winsel, Grieche, Schleim, können wir dich nicht doch noch auf unserer Newsletterliste haben und so. Das ist das erste Mal, dass man durch nichts tun irgendwas besser macht.
Also ich find das ganz gut eigentlich. Man wird immer über alles so informiert, wo man denn überhaupt noch so gespeichert ist, auch interessant von, wie man nichts hört.
Und halt auch, dass eben so die Software jetzt so ein bisschen nachzieht, was ich ja vor der Sendung schon meinte hier. Pivik, was jetzt ja, glaube ich, Momoto heisst, die haben jetzt auch gerade ein neues Release. Also für die, die es nicht wissen, das ist, wenn man Google Analytics nicht will und nicht seine User-Daten, also die User-Daten von sich an Google weiter verschenken möchte, dann kann man sich ja selber so ein Analytics Tool installieren. Und die haben jetzt auch eine neue Version rausgebracht, wo man sozusagen User-Einwilligungen wohl einblenden kann. Man kann die Daten anonymisieren lassen und man kann eben auch die Daten automatisiert von den Usern gleich löschen lassen, wenn die keinen Bock drauf haben.
Oder man reportiert, was man gespeichert hat.
Genau. Und ein automatisches Opt-out. Bei WordPress haben sie jetzt ja auch irgendwie so angefangen, so ein kleines Selbstauskunft-Plugin dazu machen, wo man mal zumindest ein paar Checkboxen anklicken kann, um mal schnell zumindest etwas da hinzuschreiben. Und das finde ich jetzt alles eigentlich erstmal echt gut. Und natürlich kommt so ein bisschen der Schmerz dazu, okay, jetzt muss ich vielleicht auch selber mal noch was machen.
Also mit Sicherheit muss man alle noch was machen.
Aber ich habe jetzt auch nicht die große Panik, wie jetzt alle. Ich habe auch schon Tweets bekommen, sorry, falls ich dich jetzt im Speziellen erwähne, lieber Hörer oder Follower, der meinte, ja, was muss ich denn jetzt mit meinem privaten SMTP-Mail-Server machen, weil da werden ja potenziell auch irgendwelche IP-Adressen und Metadaten gespeichert und so. Leute, also jetzt vielleicht nicht wirklich jeden kleinen Stein umdrehen. Gleich am Anfang, der Udo Vetter hat ja auch getweetet, also gerade so die kleinen Leute, die sollten sich jetzt nicht darum sorgen, weil die deutschen Gerichte garantiert jetzt nicht jeder jedem kleinen Furz nachgehen, sondern wahrscheinlich werden auch die Abmahnwellen erstmal die großen Beutetiere treffen.
Ich meine, die Kleinen sind ja bei Abmahnwellen immer einfacher zu treffen, weil große Firmen mahnt du nicht ab. Da kommt gleich die Rechtsabteilung und sagt, was willst du denn?
Die kloppen so doll zurück.
Das Abmahngeschäft funktioniert ja eben gerade mit Leuten, die eben keine Ahnung haben, aber Angst. Und da kommt das heran, das würde ich jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass das unberechtigt ist.
Aber ich kann mir trotzdem nicht vorstellen, dass du jetzt eine Abmahnung kriegst, weil du einen Mailserver betreibst und das dann irgendein Gericht ernten kannst.
Erstmal beweisen, dass du die IP-Adressen irgendwo im Blog speicherst. Das sehen wir erst mal nicht.
Vieles ist halt auch noch unklar und vieles ist nicht ausreichend formuliert und es wird irgendwie zu Klagen kommen und es wird irgendwas entschieden werden und diese Entscheidungen werden dann letzten Endes sagen, wohin die Reise geht. Das ist das, worauf wir uns irgendwie einstellen müssen.
Was ja interessant ist, dass du halt von einigen so dieses, bitte antwarte doch auf diese Mail bekommst und von anderen aber halt wieder so ein, wenn du darauf nicht antwortest, heißt du bist damit einverstanden. Gibt diese zwei Varianten halt irgendwie, gerade die bei mir?
Naja, ne, beziehungsweise wenn du jetzt weiter klickst, also auf der Webseite, weil eigentlich glaube ich, wenn du so ein Newsletter kriegst, da musst du aktiv werden, aber ich kenne mich da auch nicht so 100% aus. Aber auf Webseiten können sie es so machen, so formulieren, dass wenn du jetzt einfach weiter klickst oder das Schließen-Knöpfchen drückst, dann heißt das, du bist damit einverstanden.
Vielleicht war das auch speziell, also was ich auf jeden Fall, warte mal, was war denn das? Ja, müsste ich mal gucken, was das war.
Nee, ich habe auch eine E-Mail bekommen, wo im Prinzip drin stand, wenn ihr jetzt antwortet und explizit widersprecht, dann nehme ich euch raus, ansonsten gehe ich einfach davon aus, dass ihr weiter drin seid.
Ich glaube, aber das ist dann nicht...
Genau, das sagt ja auch gerade jemand.
Das ist nicht, passiert trotzdem. Ich hoffe mal, dass die dann als erstes ihre...
Ja, dass die abgewandt werden.
So ist es mal durch?
Ich bin durch, ja.
Komplett durch. Hucke hat das heute vorhin schon so schön zusammengefasst, dass ich so aussehe, wie du dich fühlst.
Ja, wobei jetzt haben wir die Roll... Also mir geht es eigentlich jetzt gerade wieder ganz gut.
Eigentlich gerade.
Was heißt jetzt, fühlst du dich so, wie sie aussieht?
Ne, jetzt nicht mehr.
Also, ihr habt es gehört, die Letti sieht heute so richtig scheiße aus.
Nicht mehr als sonst. Schon das zweite Mal, dass du heute reingeritten wirst.
Ja, das dritte Mal habt ihr nicht verpasst, das war noch ohne Mikrofon. Das sind die Sachen, die in ihrem Herzen sind.
Keinen Platz mehr haben, weil da Dr. Who und noch was anderes drin ist.
Und 80 Terabyte Patienten-Daten.
Nee, die sind nicht in meinem Herzen. Nee, nicht mal so ansatzweise.
Nur die Toten.
So viele Tote hab ich nicht. Naja, wir haben schon so Patienten, die inzwischen tot sind.
Gut Leute, vielen schönen Happy Taule Day. Ich hoffe, einige von euch treffen wir am Samstag bei Lokbohren Expedit 256. Das steht auch noch an diese Woche. Und ansonsten alle anderen, hört ihr uns bald wieder in zwei Wochen. Tala, vielen, vielen Dank fürs Kommen. Das war super Spaß.
Ich bin jetzt aber erstmal weg.
Das waren die letzten Worte, die mir jetzt eingefallen sind. Haben wir irgendwas vergessen?
Warten. Ich paste noch schnell einen Link hier rein, den ich heute auch hier gerade noch gesehen habe.
Willst du jetzt ein neues Thema aufmachen?
Danke an die Hörer für Amazon-Geschenke.
Genau.
Tschüss.
Von heute, die Dialing 999 wird dich nicht die Urheberungsservices bekommen. Nüsse Ambulanzen, schneller Response-Zeiten und besser-sehende Fahrer bedeuten nicht nur die Urheberungsservices, sie sind auch deine Urheberungsservices.